5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Im Chat zur Sendung wird gerade gefragt, was kommt eigentlich nach 10? Und es ist verwunderlich, dass das noch nicht rausgefunden wurde, wo doch schon seit Jahren hier am letzten Donnerstag im Monat immer diese Erkennungsmelodie läuft. Die bedeutet, es ist Zeit fürs Chaosradio in Blumen. Chaosradio heißt, der Chaos Computer Club kommt und bringt Leute mit, die möglicherweise über ein Thema erzählen, das irgendwie mit den seltsamen Dingen zu tun hat, die da draus mit Strom funktionieren. Vielleicht auch das seltsame Internet, von dem alle reden. Ich glaube nicht, das setzt sich durch. Aber darum geht es hier manchmal. Und zu Gast vom Chaos Computer Club ist heute zum Beispiel der Herr Erdgeist. Hallo und guten Abend. Und hat mitgemacht den, jetzt weiß ich nicht genau, den ILF. Hallo, guten Abend, auch vom Chaos Computer Club. Hallihallo. Und den Andre Meister von netzpolitik.org, der sich dort viel mit europäischer Politik beschäftigt. Hallo Andre.
Schönen guten Abend.
Außerdem haben wir noch heute zugeschaltet von weiter Ferne, nämlich direkt aus Brüssel, Kirsten Fiedler. Hallo, guten Abend.
Hallo.
Und falls es da heute zu Problemen kommt, dann müsst ihr uns das nachsehen. Denn wir arbeiten heute mit Raketentechnik. Ihr glaubt nicht, wie schwierig das ist, aber tatsächlich machen wir heute per Voice-over-IP eine direkte Leitung in ein fremdes Land und bringen das dann ins Radio. Das ist für uns vom Oldschool-Radio immer nicht so einfach, aber wir hoffen, dass das gut geht. Aber worum geht es heute eigentlich? Es geht heute um Clean-IT. Das ist einerseits so eine Idee, weil immer wieder taucht bei Politikern die Vorstellung auf, dieser ganze Digitalkram, diese ganze Computer, diese ganze Software und vor allem auch dieses ganze Internet, das kann man irgendwie sauber kriegen, das kann man irgendwie ungefährlich kriegen und das kann man irgendwie so kriegen, dass da alle Regeln jedes Mal eingehalten werden. Und im Zuge dessen ist es auch ganz praktisch, wenn wir genau wissen, wer wo was wann macht. Andererseits ist es auch gerade ein konkretes, naja, also was es genau ist, das kleine Wort auch noch, es ging aber auf jeden Fall durch die Presse, durch die Nachrichten, dass da in der EU irgendwie was besprochen wurde, was diesen Namen tragen soll und was halt ganz seltsame Forderungen stellt, die wir auch an dieser Stelle näher erläutern wollen werden. Ihr könnt, wenn ihr heute hier während der Sendung eine Frage habt oder einen relevanten Gesprächsbeitrag leisten wollt, gerne anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110 und auch etwas zum Thema beitragen. Bevor wir jetzt aber wirklich damit anfangen, wollen wir erstmal klären, worum es eigentlich geht. Also ich habe tatsächlich nur durch meine Timeline bei Twitter und sonst wo gesehen, CleanIT, oh nein, was denken sich die schlimmen EU-Politiker schon wieder aus? Andre hat ja fürs Blog Netzpolitik auch viele Artikel zu dem Thema geschrieben und kann uns vielleicht am besten erläutern, was genau steht denn in diesem Papier, das diesen Namen trägt? Was wird da gefordert?
Ja, CleanIT ist ein Projekt von Anti-Terror-Bekämpfern von ein paar EU-Staaten, die sich zusammengetan haben. Ich meine, im Internet gibt es viel zu viele Inhalte von Terrorismus und allgemein schädlichen Inhalten. Die haben das nicht so ganz genau definiert, was das eigentlich das Problem ist. Jedenfalls wollen sie mal was dagegen tun und haben in diversen Treffen Leute eingeladen, die irgendwie sich denken, sich mit Internet und Terrorismus auszukennen, die dann einen Haufen Vorschläge gemacht haben, was man denn gegen diesen ganzen bösen Schund im Internet tun kann und das Internet wieder sauber zu kriegen. Und herauskommt eine Horrorliste an Politikvorschlägen oder auch Vorschlägen, wie man das ganz ohne Politik direkt mit Providern, in AGBs zum Beispiel, lösen kann, die einmal jeden schlechten Vorschlag, den wir in den letzten paar Jahren schon gehört haben, auflistet und ein paar neue dazu macht. Dazu gehört ein Alarmknopf fürs Internet. Dazu gehört die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die ganz wichtig ist. Dazu gehört die Überwachung und Filterung von Netzanschlüssen. Dazu gehört ein Verbot auf terroristische Inhalte, was auch immer das ist, zu linken. Dazu gehört irgendwie eine Policies, damit Leute sich im Internet nicht mehr anonym bewegen dürfen, sondern überall ihren klaren Namen angeben können. Dazu gehört die Möglichkeit, dass Polizisten und andere Behörden sich in sozialen Netzwerken tummeln können und sich dort als Personen ausgeben können, um irgendwelche Kreise zu identifizieren. Und vieles Weitere. Einmal, dass es so jung ist, schlechte Internetpolitik.
Jetzt ist das sozusagen da so rumgegangen, hat auch für den fast schon erwartungsgemäßen Aufschrei gesorgt. Erdgeist, im Chaos Computer Club selber, wie war da die Reaktion? Wurde das überhaupt noch wahrgenommen? Oder ist das dann eher so, ja, okay, da sind die Leute wieder?
Es ist schön, dass dort sämtliche schlechten Vorschläge immer wieder schön zusammengefasst werden. Man verliert ja auch so ein bisschen den Überblick, was gerade wieder an blöden Ideen dadurch durch die Welt wabert. Und wenn sich Leute die Mühe geben, auch noch von EU-Kommissionen mitfinanziert solche Listen zusammenzustellen, dann hat man schön mal auf einem Zettel zusammen, welche Baustellen man nicht vergessen darf. Fand ich sehr höflich von denen.
Kirsten, du sitzt jetzt direkt in Brüssel und arbeitest bei EDRI. EDRI, erklär doch mal erst mal ganz kurz, was das überhaupt ist.
Ja, also EDRI arbeitet quasi auch für den Chaos Computer Club. Wir vertreten hier in Brüssel 32 Bürgerrechts- und Datenschutzorganisationen aus 20 europäischen Ländern. Wir arbeiten wie viele Organisationen über Mailinglisten. Wir versuchen eigentlich hier alles abzudenken, was unsere amerikanischen Kollegen von der EFF mit über 20 Leuten machen. Wir sind hier nur drei und das geht also vom Urheberrecht über alle möglichen komischen Projekte zur privatisierten Rechtsdurchsetzung, Internetsperren, Vorratsdatenspeicherung bis zum Datenschutz.
Und wie ist jetzt sagen dieses Thema Clean IT? Das ist ja bei uns kam das sozusagen, also ich weiß nicht ob auch in der Zeitung, habe ich natürlich gar nicht mitgekriegt, aber auf jeden Fall sagen im Netz ging es rum. Wie hat euch das erreicht? Wusstet ihr das vorher schon oder habt ihr es auch daher erfahren?
Nein, also wir haben uns wurde das Dokument ja überhaupt erst zugespielt und wir haben das veröffentlicht letzten Freitag. Und wir sind an dem Projekt eigentlich schon seit 2010 dran.
Und kannst du auch noch mal sagen, was ist da, was findest du das Krasseste daran? Oder ist es für dich auch nur sozusagen so ein Sammelsurium von schlechten Dingen?
Also es gibt da mehrere krasse Sachen dran. Also erst mal ist es halt eine ganze Liste an Vira Vorschläge. Also das Dokument ist 23 Seiten lang. Und das wirklich Schlimmste daran ist eigentlich, dass die EU-Kommission schon seit Jahren versucht, über diverse Projekte Unternehmen dazu zu bringen, das also recht durchzusetzen.
Das heißt, dass wir in Zukunft nicht mehr eine Rechtsbehörden haben, sondern dass die Firmen das selber machen sollen. In welcher Art und Weise stellen die sich das vor? Wie soll das passieren, dass die Firmen das recht durchsetzen und nicht mehr die Polizei?
Ja, also wie Andre eben meinte, das kann durch AGBs funktionieren oder Internet sperren, durch allgemeine Geschäftsbedingungen. Ich glaube, 2010 gab es schon mal ein ähnliches Projekt und da hat die EU-Kommission ganz speziell Internetprovider, also Serviceprovider, darauf hingewiesen, dass die Mitgliedstaaten sie zwar nicht dazu zwingen können, zum Beispiel die Packet-Inspection einzusetzen und das Internet zu überwachen, aber dass sie gerne freiwillige Maßnahmen einbringen können.
Okay, also in die AGBs wieder reingeschrieben, ihr dürft nichts Böses mehr tun. Andre, hat dazu etwas?
So ungefähr. Der Ansatz von CleanIT ist ja eines sogenannten Private-Public-Partnerships, in dem sich die Strafverfolgungsbehörden direkt mit Internetfirmen zusammensetzen und dann gemeinsam auf kurzem Dienstweg diskutieren, was man denn alles gegen die schlimmen Dinge im Internet machen kann, um dann, wie es in dem ersten Dokument, was wir veröffentlicht haben, hieß, nicht legislativ Vorschläge zu machen, wie man zum Beispiel Leuten in AGBs, das ist ein großer Ansatz, verbieten kann, bestimmte Sachen mit ihnen, Services, die die Firmen anbieten, zu machen, was natürlich für beide Seiten den Vorteil hat. Das geht viel schneller. Man muss sich umständlich über irgendwelche Gesetze und womöglich noch Parlamente und Öffentlichkeit gehen, in so einem Entscheidungsverfahren, was aber auch genau der große Kritikpunkt daran geht. Wenn dieses Dokument Grundrechtseingriffe vorschlägt, dann ist das nicht mal einfach so, auf einem kurzen Dienstweg zwischen Strafverfolgungsbehörden und Providern zu machen, auch wenn das leider immer mehr in Mode kommt. Es gab ja schon vor kurzem ein Beispiel, dass Microsoft in seiner neumolischen Cloud-Wolke Nacktbilder von Usern entfernt, die aber professionelle Fotografen sind und Models fotografiert haben, aber das in amerikanischer Konzern ist. Und da irgendwie zu viel Haut beim Filter angeschlagen ist, wurde sein ganzer Account gesperrt und seine ganzen Daten gelöscht. Solche Sachen können passieren, wenn in AGBs drin steht, du darfst dieses oder jenes nicht.
Jetzt habt ihr erzählt, dass es bei Klinikative sagen, dass der Ansatz war Terroristenbekämpfer. Jetzt wäre das ja die erste Initiative zur Einschränkung des Internets, wo es dann tatsächlich dabei bleibt, dass es nur um das eine Thema geht. Sind da möglicherweise hinten dran noch so andere Dinge passiert? Also sowas wie, man könnte ja vielleicht auch die Falscherer gleich mit...
Ja, das große Problem ist, dass Klinikative nie definiert hat, was denn nun eigentlich der Terrorismus ist, den man da bekämpfen will. Irgendwie waberte das dann von Terrorismus zu der illegalen Benutzung des Internets usw. Und in einem Dokument haben wir gefunden, Terrorismus kann sein, tierrechte, linksextreme, rassistische, religiöse, rechtsextreme, separatistische und alle anderen terroristischen und extremistischen Organisationen und Einzelpersonen.
Das Problem bei Terrorismus ist, dass jede der gängigen Definitionen da draußen immer so weit gefasst ist, dass eigentlich auch 90 Prozent aller lupenreinen Demokratien mit unter dieser Terrorismusdefinition fallen würden in engster Auslegung. Deswegen drücken sie sich halt immer darum, den Begriff Terrorismus mal in irgendeinem Gesetz ordentlich zu definieren.
Also sollte jemand in Bayern zum Beispiel fordern, dass der Freistaat doch endlich mal selbstständig wird von der BED, wäre das möglicherweise auch schon ein Terrorist und könnte dann... Ja, das ist sehr schön. Jetzt wollen wir heute länger und ausführlicher, also erstmal darüber sprechen, ob das Ganze politisch machbar ist in der Art und Weise, wie es vorgeschlagen wird und dann auch, wie es überhaupt zu diesen ganzen Vorschlägen kommt. Ich würde aber tatsächlich gerne nochmal wissen, was Sie da fordern. Eine Verständnisfrage muss ich noch stellen. Die Packet-Inspection von jedem, der es noch nicht gehört hat, nochmal ganz kurz erläutert.
Die Packet-Inspection bedeutet, dass an den Schaltstellen im Internet, wo einmal die Pakete durchgehen müssen, sei es bei deinem ISP, also bei deinem Internetanbieter, oder bei Firmen, die so riesengroße Computer rumstehen haben, wo die Pakete dann verteilt werden, dass die mit ziemlich effizienter Technik in alle Pakete einmal reinkieken und nicht nur auf die Verkehrsdaten, also nicht mehr gucken von wo nach wo, sondern wirklich auf die Inhalte versuchen, Pakete zusammenzusetzen, wieder zu Verbindungen, um eine grobe Übersicht zu bekommen, was denn da drin abgeht, und dann nach dieser Inspection meistens Filterregeln, Shapingregeln oder Notifikationen an Bedarfsträger zu vermitteln.
Also wenn da zum Beispiel eine sozusagen große Menge an hochauflösenden Fortklassungsdokumentationen teilt, dann kann man das möglicherweise sagen, die Bandbreite ein bisschen einschränken.
Genau, in dem gibt man dann mehr Bandbreite, weil der hat ja wahrscheinlich dafür eher noch bezahlt. Wenn er aber eher aus dem Internet sich hochauflösende Hollywood-Dokumentationen ohne zu bezahlen angucken möchte, dann wird er dann gerundert rosselt.
Oder man kann halt auch sozusagen überwachen, was da sozusagen für eine Art rumkommt. Ich will jetzt haben wir schon nachgefragt, nee Quatsch, FALT, immer schön beim Thema bleiben. Technische Realisierbarkeit, also Deep Pack inspection, das ist ja was, das taucht immer mal wieder auf, das können die Provider überhaupt. Ist denn dieser CleanRide-Team-Katalog, wenn man den jetzt sagen würde, als Vorlage nehmen würde und einfach einen Techniker heransetzt, erst mal ohne die Politik zu diskutieren, ließe der sich umsetzen? Also ginge das oder werden da auch Sachen gefordert, die es eigentlich gar nicht gibt?
Pfff, kommt drauf an, was man jetzt noch höflich als Internet bezeichnen würde. Du kannst natürlich irgendjemanden das Internet auf CD in seinen Computer reinschieben und sagen, du kannst alle HTML-Dokumente, die jemand gesichtet hat, die hier auf dieser CD drauf sind, jetzt klicken mit deinem Browser, sieht ein bisschen aus wie Internet und wäre halt theoretisch möglich.
Naja, aber zum Beispiel einer der Vorstöße, die mir ins Auge gefallen sind, sind soziale Netzwerke, sollen nur noch mit dem realen Namen, also der realen Identität benutzt werden können. Gibt es da überhaupt schon eine technische Vorlage, wie man sowas machen will?
Die E-Mail.
Erklär mal kurz, für alle, die das nicht kennen, ist ja noch nicht so verbreitet der Dienst.
Noch nicht. Noch nicht. Die E-Mail ist so ein... Es soll so ähnlich wie E-Mail funktionieren, aber dann nicht wie E-Mail. Man muss vorher sich mit seinem Personalausweis bei der Post so eine Mailadresse abholen und danach kann man dahin einigermaßen verschlüsselt, naja verschleiert, rechtswirksame Dokumente sich schicken lassen. Das Blöde ist, wenn man sie da erst mal hingeschickt bekommen hat, kann man sich nicht mehr rausreden, man hätte sie nicht bekommen, weil man hat sie ja bekommen. Und dort hängt aber dein Name mit dran. Und das heißt, dass du dann entweder den Postbeamten, bei dem du dort irgendein Ausweisdokument, dein Lichtbildausweis vorgelegt hast, ihnen davon überzeugen kannst, dass du das bist, oder, na, du kriegst keinen anonymen oder kein pseudonym Zugang zum Internet.
Ich kann also fest sagen, es wäre dann in Zukunft so, man kann sich nicht mal eben in einen neuen Account von Tumblelock klicken, sondern müsste dann immer sozusagen den Hersteller...
Ja doch, man kann sich bestimmt auch einen neuen Account da in einen Blog klicken, aber da hängt dann am Ende immer noch dein Name mit dran.
Der muss ja erstmal verifiziert werden, dann müsstest du wahrscheinlich erst mal Postzetteln her schicken.
Nein, du würdest dann einfach signiert wahrscheinlich eine D-E-Mail los schicken.
Ah, verstehe. Gut, Andre, du hattest dazu noch was?
Ein anderer Vorschlag, der in diesem Dokument steht, sind Filter beim Upload zu Internetdiensten oder auch in Firmennetzwerken, wobei dann noch ein Zusatz drin ist, dass Anbieter, die Filter zur Verfügung stellen und verkaufen, dann auch dafür verantwortlich gemacht werden, dass die auch richtig funktionieren. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt einen Filter installiere und der filtert eine Seite aus Versehen nicht, dann könnte ich dafür haftbar sein. Die logische Konsequenz wäre natürlich, dass Filterhersteller nicht Seiten auf eine schwarze Liste stellen, eine Blacklist machen, sondern andersrum, dass erstmal das Internet sperren und dann nur die guten sachten Whitelisten. Und das wäre dann tatsächlich, um deine Frage zu beantworten, kein Internet mehr, sondern eine Art AOL oder europäisches Online.
AOL-Aktien sollen dann gerade tierisch gestiegen sein, habe ich gehört.
Ja, so wie Facebook.
Wieso seitdem Windows 8 aussehen wie AOL?
Nein, ich habe das noch nicht gehört. Also Facebook verliert, Google verliert oder steigt nur so gering. Und AOL hat irgendwie 120 Prozent zugelegt. Das gibt mir ein bisschen zu denken. Jetzt ist ja meine Vorstellung von jemand, der als Internetbetreiber arbeitet oder so eine Softwareprogramme. Wenn ihr jemand ankommt und sagt, bitte bau doch mal so ein kaputtes Internet, dann würde ich mir an den Kopf fassen und sagen, ne will ich nicht. Wie reagiert denn die Industrie da drauf? Gibt es da Sachen? Kirsten, weißt du da vielleicht was?
Puh, ja, also ich glaube, die EU-Kommission ist ziemlich begeistert von Microsofts Uploadfiltern, also was sich Fotodna schimpft und ja.
Also ist es gar nicht so, dass die Politik etwas fordert und die Industrie jetzt sozusagen sich die Hände reibt, weil sie damit Geld verdienen kann oder total erschreckt ist, sondern die Idee kommt eigentlich aus der Industrie?
Das ganze CleanIT-Projekt ist so, dass da ein paar Beamte, eben Anti-Terror-Bekämpfer, sich hinsetzen und denken, was können wir denn gegen den bösen Content im Internet tun? Laden dazu einen Haufen Internetfirmen ein, was die denn für Möglichkeiten vorschlagen, was sie dann selbst tun könnten. Und die allermeisten Firmen, die in den letzten Runden mit dabei waren, waren eben solche Hersteller von Filtersoftware, die dann gedacht haben, oh, es gibt hier ein Geschäftsmodell, ich kann meine Software verkaufen. Dementsprechend sind dann auch deren Vorschläge in den Papieren gelandet.
Also die Firma sagt dann nicht sozusagen, oh mein Gott, ich soll euch einen Filter bauen, wo ich jede einzelne Webseite erlauben muss. Das wird doch viel zu kompliziert. Sondern die sagen, das mache ich euch gerne, das ist nämlich tierisch aufwendig, dann kann ich viel Geld nehmen, von wem auch immer.
Genau.
Erstmal muss ich diese Explorationsstelle ja selber tragen. Das ist meistens nicht so schwer. Da kannst du jemanden einstellen, der geht rum, liest die ganzen Ausschreibungen der EU und dann bekommt er dafür die Firma Kohle ran, die dann Projekte durchspezifiziert, die dann so ungefähr da draufpassen. Und da, bevor die Firma damit Geld verdient, reicht es ja, wenn die Stelle, die sie damit besetzen muss, dass jemand da rumgeht und sich diese Projekte ausbeidobert und den richtigen Topf bei der EU dafür ausfindig macht. Solange die nicht rote Zahlen schreibt, ist ja so eine Person erstmal nicht verschwendet für so eine Firma.
An welcher Stelle sind wir jetzt? Sind wir jetzt gerade da sozusagen?
Du fragst, ob Firmen sich dann die Finger lecken. Und ich sage, dass die müssen sich erstmal noch nicht die Finger lecken, sondern machen so ein bisschen Landschaftspflege und kriegen die Stelle dann auch noch bezahlt von irgendjemanden, der sich dann damit EU-Recht...
Also man verdient sozusagen als Firma, die sozusagen Internetzeug programmiert oder herstellt, schon damit Geld, indem man einfach solche Vorschläge unterbreitet?
Und das große Problem, denke ich mal, sind hierbei auch noch die Kriterien, um überhaupt an EU-Fördergelder im Sicherheitsbereich zu kommen. Weil die sind nämlich ziemlich unklar. Und ich glaube, in einem aktuellen Verordnungsentwurf zu Fördergeldern im Sicherheitsbereich steht zum Beispiel drin, dass dazu alles gehört, was irgendwie dazu beiträgt, das Unsicherheitsgefühl der Bürger abzubauen.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich kann gerade nicht mehr so richtig folgen. Vielleicht fangen wir dann doch einfach mal von vorne an. Und zwar möchte ich noch die Frage stellen, in den Leuten, die darüber geredet haben, wird ja Clean IT auch mit ACTA irgendwie in einen Topf geworfen. Wenn man zumindest andere das gefragt hat, dann sagt der so, hat den Kopf gestellt, nein, das ist was völlig anderes. Okay, erklär doch mal den Unterschied. Wo ist es dasselbe und wo ist es ein Unterschied?
Gemeinsamkeiten gibt es, dass sowohl Clean IT als auch ACTA keine originären Veranstaltungen der Europäischen Kommission oder der EU sind. Clean IT hatte zwar einen Vorläufer in einem Projekt der EU-Kommission, aber dann hat sich ein niederländischer Anti-Terror-Bekämpfer den Hut aufgesetzt und hat gesagt, ich mache jetzt mal was gegen den Terrorismus im Internet. Und hat sich ein paar Leute vom Innenministerium von Deutschland, ein paar anderen Staaten und von Europol genommen und gesagt, ich mache jetzt das Clean IT Projekt und werde mal gucken, was wir gegen den Terrorismus im Internet machen können. Dann haben sie einen Antrag geschrieben und haben an die Europäische Kommission bzw. an die richtige Stelle das DJ Home Department davon, in etwa das Innenministerium, geschickt, um von deren Sicherheitsforschungstopf Kohle abzugreifen. 400.000 Euro bekommen und organisieren damit jetzt Konferenzen, zu denen sie Terrorbekämpfer verschiedener EU-Staaten, so wie die beteiligte Internetindustrie, was auch immer das ist, einladen, um eben Vorschläge zu sammeln, wie man dem Terror im Internet herwerden könnte. Und dieses Papier, was European Digital Rights letzten Freitag veröffentlicht hat, ist eben eine Zusammenstellung all dieser Vorschläge, die auf diesen fünf, sechs Arbeitskonferenzen, die CleanIT bisher veranstaltet hat, zusammengekommen sind. Und jetzt gibt es noch ein Treffen November in Wien. Und dann wird im Februar das Schlussdokument in Brüssel vorgestellt. Dann ist CleanIT abgeschlossen und hat Handlungsempfehlungen für wen auch immer. Eigentlich ist die Idee, dass sie damit direkt zu den Providern gehen, die diese Sachen in ihre AGBs aufnehmen sollen. Jetzt hat man munkeln gehört, dass nicht jeder Provider darüber wahnsinnig erfreut ist, jetzt sein Internet zensieren zu sollen oder andere Sachen in die AGBs zu schreiben. Es ist die Frage, wie weit die sich überhaupt durchsetzen können. Die Verbindung zur EU-Kommission ist, CleanIT hat Geld von der EU-Kommission bekommen. Aber das ist eines von vielen, vielen Forschungsprojekten, die da laufen. Und tatsächlich glaube ich, dass nicht jeder Kommissionsbeamte weiß, welche ganzen Fördergelder da runterlaufen. Die Schlagzeilen, die EU macht, ist tatsächlich ein bisschen übertrieben. Das ist erst mal ein Würrervorschlag von Terrorbekämpfern, der aber ganz gut die Wasserstandsmeldungen zeigt, wie Strafverfolgungsbehörden denn teilweise das Internet sehen und was für ein böser Hott der Kriminalität das angesehen wird und was man da für Möglichkeiten sich ausmalt, die man da drauf werfen könnte.
Wenn ich jetzt nochmal mit Akta vergleiche, ist es also kein Vertrag, der offiziell irgendwie behandelt wird, sondern ein Projekt einer Gruppe, die von der EU Geld bekommen hat. Trotzdem, vom Sportsgeist her, ist es ja doch irgendwie ähnlich.
Wollen wir doch mal gut dabei die Fische machen. Wer sitzt denn da an diesem Tisch? Wer sitzt denn da an diesem Clean-IT-Tisch?
Das sind Terrorbekämpfer von mehreren Staaten. Ich habe heute eine Informationsfreiheit-Gesetzanfrage an das Innenministerium gestellt. Wer denn von denen dabei war, habe leider noch keine Antwort bekommen. Dann diverse Provider und eben Filterhersteller. Eine genaue Liste habe ich jetzt noch nicht. CleanIT Project hat ein paar Teilnehmerinnen und Teilnehmer der letzten Sitzung auf seiner Webseite veröffentlicht, was zu dem lustigen Effekt führte, dass da der Vizechef der Schweizer Piratenpartei drauf war. Aber da sind irgendwie ein Haufen Leute, die irgendwas denken, mit diesem Terrorismus im Internet zu tun zu haben und mit der Internetwirtschaft zu tun zu haben.
Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, der Unterschied zu Akta ist mir zu sagen, als einfachem, normalen Bürger noch nicht klar geworden. Also klar, ich habe jetzt gelernt, das ist sozusagen ein Ding, also eine Handlungsempfehlung quasi und nicht ein Vertrag. Aber letztendlich haben da Leute, die es für eine gute Idee finden, gesagt, wir machen das jetzt mal ein bisschen weniger frei. Und das ist ja das, was bei Akta auch so hängen geblieben ist.
Also Akta wurde ja von der EU-Kommission aktiv mitverhandelt und dieses CleanIT-Projekt eigentlich nur in Anführungszeichen finanziert.
Niemand von der Kommission sitzt offiziell bei diesem CleanIT-Projekt. Bei den ganzen Akta-Verhandlungsrunden saßen Leute der deutschen Regierung und der Europäischen Kommission die ganze Zeit am Tisch und haben aktiv Verhandlungen geführt. Und da waren auch nicht wirklich, das sind jetzt wieder Gemeinsamkeiten, auch nicht wirklich Zivilgesellschaft am Tisch. Und Akta sollte dann irgendwann als völkerrechtlich bindender Vertrag verabschiedet werden, was aber auch heißt, dass dieser Vertrag in die Parlamente geht, in den Deutschen Bundestag und in das Europaparlament. Und Akta ist zum Glück im Europaparlament abgewendet worden, quasi einmal niedergeschmettert. Damit ist Akta jetzt erstmal tot. CleanIT geht gar nicht in den Parlament. Da haben gewählte Parlamentarier überhaupt nichts zu entscheiden, sondern das nümpelt da so rum.
Das ist tatsächlich aber so, also die Idealvorstellung der Leute, die das machen ist, wir machen diese Handlungsempfehlung und dann geben wir das direkt an die Provider.
Genau, an die Internetindustrie.
Genau, also keinen Umweg über irgendwelche demokratisch legitimierten Elemente.
Es gibt da Teile da drinnen, die einfach auch die nationalen Parlamente dazu anhalten, bestimmte rechtliche Voraussetzungen wieder abzuschaffen, die ISPs daran hindern zu speichern zum Beispiel. Das muss natürlich dann auch wieder durch die nationalen Parlamente, aber was denkst du denn?
Halt, an dieser Stelle unterbreche ich das Gespräch für eine kurze Pause. Ich will gleich mit euch tatsächlich darüber sprechen, inwieweit das denn dieses Projekt jetzt, was erstmal noch nicht von der EU-Kommission verhandelt wurde offiziell, inwieweit das da möglicherweise gelitten ist, was die Leute davon erhalten und inwieweit ihr denkt, dass man das vielleicht tatsächlich politisch durchsetzen kann. Wir werden das gleich alles sehr ausführlich besprechen. Vorher gibt es aber das Fritz Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr.
Hallo, ich bin Marion, die schwebende Jungfrau.
Aufgepasst. Habt ihr gesehen?
Ähm, Marion, also wenn du so jungfraulich bist, wie du schwebst, dann äh...
Au!
Ist doch nicht so schlimm.
Üb doch einfach noch ein bisschen.
Also das Schweben.
Auf der Bühne die unentdeckten Talente. Also hier außerdem die Gewinner der letzten Nacht der Talente.
Ein geiler Überraschungs-Act und ein Radio, das den ganzen Abend in die ganze Welt überträgt.
Die Fritz Nacht der Talente. Samstag, 13.
Oktober im Großen Saal vom Admiralspalast Berlin. Solang es noch Karten gibt, gibt es Karten auf bei Fritz im Netz.
Die Fritz Nacht der Talente.
Moderiert von den Radio-Fritzen Katrin Thüring und Chris Guse. Der ständige Euro-Rettungsschirm ESM kommt. Heute Nachmittag hat Bundespräsident Gauck die Ratifizierungsurkunde unterschrieben. Damit kann der Rettungsschirm in knapp zwei Wochen in Kraft treten. Er hat eine Höhe von 500 Milliarden Euro und soll pleitebedrohte Euro-Länder unterstützen. Deutschland beteiligt sich am Rettungsschirm mit maximal 190 Milliarden Euro. In Ostdeutschland sind mehr als 4000 Kinder und Jugendliche an verunreinigtem Essen erkrankt. Ein Sprecher des Robert Koch Instituts sagte, dass Berlin, Brandenburg, Sachsen und Thüringen betroffen sind. Nach RBB-Informationen sind in Brandenburg mehr als 1100 Kinder und Jugendliche erkrankt, in Berlin etwa 400. Auch einige Lehrer sind erkrankt. Auslöser ist wahrscheinlich das Essen des Großanbieters für Kita- und Schulessen Zodexo aus Thüringen. Berlins Inn-Senator Henkel muss nicht vor dem NSU-Untersuchungsausschuss des Bundestages aussagen. Die Ausschussmitglieder wiesen einen Antrag der Grünen ab. Auch Berlins amtierender Polizeipräsidentin Koppers wird nicht vorgeladen. Die Grünen wollten Henkel zu seinen Erkenntnissen zur V-Mann-Affäre befragen. Zuletzt war bekannt geworden, dass die Berliner Polizei jahrelang mit dem mutmaßlichen NSU-Unterstützer Thomas S zusammengearbeitet hat und diese Informationen dem Untersuchungsausschuss mehr als ein halbes Jahr lang vorenthielt. Henkel hat inzwischen einen Sonderermittler eingesetzt. Facebook geht offenbar gegen gefälschte Profile vor. Das soziale Netzwerk soll angefangen haben, Profile zu löschen, die es als unecht einstuft. Das berichtet das Technologie-Blog TechCrunch. Facebook selbst schätzt, dass es über 80 Millionen gefälschte Profile gibt. Wetter Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen. In Berlin haben wir es überall zwischen 14 und 15 Grad, in Wittenberge 12, Cottbus Neuropin-Angermünde Mellen 13 und Potsdam und Frankfurt 14 Grad. Nachts bleibt es weiter regnerisch und wolkig, erst später lockert es dann etwas auf. Die Temperaturen sinken dabei auf 12 bis 10 Grad. Und morgen wird es dann wieder regnerisch und wolkig, das Ganze bei 15 bis 18 Grad. Verkehr Nichts los auf den Straßen, in Berlin und Brandenburg, wir wünschen euch eine gute Fahrt. Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Heute Chaosradio im Blue Moon. Und wir sprechen über Clean IT, ein Projekt, das der Terrorismusbekämpfung im Internet dient, aber möglicherweise ein paar kleine Kritikpunkte hat. Und wollen im Zusammenhang damit auch mal darüber sprechen, wie in der EU eigentlich solche Dinge immer wieder zu Tage treten. Bevor wir weitermachen, gibt es aber einen kleinen, süßen Creative-Common-Song namens Totentanz. So, schöne Musik von Caldron, ne Totentanz ist das, ist auf dem Free Music Sampler drauf, der dieses Jahr rausgekommen ist. Herzlich willkommen zurück beim Chaosradio, wo wir über CleanIT sprechen. CleanIT ist ein Projekt, das mit EU-Fördergeldern mal zusammengetragen hat, was man alles so machen könnte, um das Internet so richtig sicher zu machen. Also zum Beispiel könnte man den Providern auftragen, dass sie mal alle Inhalte zensieren, die irgendwie terroristisch sind, ohne genau zu wissen, was das ist. Ein soziales Netzwerk dürfte nur noch mit echtem Namen unterwegs sein und naja, so Sachen halt. Wir wollen heute mal erklären, warum die EU immer wieder auf diese Ideen kommt und das sozusagen an diesem Beispiel machen. Dazu begrüße ich Erdgeist vom Chaos Computer Club.
Willkommen zurück.
Ilf vom Chaos Computer Club. Hallihallo. Kirsten Fiedler von EDRI.
Da haben wir wen verloren.
Da bin ich.
Die moderne Technik. Und außerdem Andre Meister vom Blognetzpolitik-Org. Hallo und guten Abend. Hallihallo. So, wir waren jetzt gerade dabei stehen geblieben, dass ich eigentlich von euch genau mal rausfinden wollte, was eigentlich jetzt diese, also wie das zur Startekommunikation, wie gesagt, der Unterschied zu ACTA ist, dass ACTA verhandelt wurde von hochoffiziell der EU-Kommission, aber dieses Clean-A.T. von dem wir letzte Woche gehört haben, das ist nur von einer EU-Kommission irgendwie gefördert worden, aber eigentlich weiß da jetzt noch so richtig keiner, was von den Oberen, so klang es zumindest gerade für mich. Ist das denn wirklich so, also wissen die davon nichts und sind jetzt auch genauso überrascht, wie wir alle, was sich diese komischen Leute ausgedacht haben oder wie wird das da wahrgenommen in diesem Apparat?
Das kann ich nicht ganz genauer sagen. Wir haben auch heute angefragt, welchen Ausschreibungstext, Clean-A.T. welchen Antrag, den die dann überhaupt abgegeben haben, um die 400.000 Euro Kohle zu bekommen. Wie viele Leute in der Kommission bzw. in dem Teil DG Home quasi dem Innenministerium über die ganzen Projekte, die sie fördern, Bescheid wissen, kann ich nicht sagen. Die EU-Kommissarin Cecilia Malmström hat sich aber in den letzten Tagen auf Twitter ziemlich deutlich von Clean-A.T. distanziert. Das sei ja nur von ihr finanziert und nicht von ihr initiiert oder gefördert. Das sei auch nicht ihre Politik, sondern das läuft halt irgendwie unter Diskussionsvorschlägen. Und ich glaube, da kommt schon ganz schön durch, dass spätestens seit Akta einige Politiker auch in der EU Angst vor diesem bösen Internet, von dem wir alle reden, haben. Aber gerade Cecilia Malmström hat auch schon ihre ganz eigenen Erfahrungen mit dem Internet gemacht. Wir hier in Deutschland hatten ja die unsägliche Debatte um Zensosola und Netzsperren gegen Kindesmissbrauchstokumentationen. In der EU gab es das auch, auch mit Frau Malmström. Und die hat sich dann mit dem Internet angelegt und den Spitznamen Cecilia verdient. Deswegen ist sie jetzt ein bisschen vorsichtig geworden, möchte sich nicht nochmal mit dem Internet anlegen, wie sie in zwei Jahren als Liberale wieder zurück nach Schweden gehen will. Und schiebt sowohl die Vorratszeitenspeicherung ein bisschen auf die lange Bank, als auch hat sie sich jetzt ziemlich schnell und recht deutlich von Clean IT distanziert.
Für wie glaubwürdig haltet ihr diese Distanzierung?
Dass die Frau das nicht nochmal erleben möchte, glaube ich ihr sehr gerne.
Ja, das können wir so fest sagen.
Naja, aber jetzt mal ehrlich sozusagen, ist das jetzt so ein Ding, dass das halt an die Öffentlichkeit kommt und deswegen distanziert man sich jetzt mal schnell? Oder ist das wirklich sozusagen, okay, wir wollten halt tatsächlich mal hören, was sie wollen, aber das interessiert uns jetzt erstmal nicht, sozusagen zumindest nicht bindend.
Ich glaube, da kann Kirsten ein bisschen mehr dazu sagen, denn die Kommission ist ja kein monolithischer Block, sondern hat viele organische Arme und Ausprägungen.
Das ist jetzt der Punkt, wo wir irgendwie mal mit der EU anfangen.
So, jetzt ist der Punkt, liebe Leute, falls ihr unter Umständen gerade für das Unterrichtsfach Politik lernt und mal sozusagen die EU möglicherweise gerade dran habt, wir müssen jetzt mal drüber reden. Es kommt euch vielleicht trocken vor, aber ihr müsst immer im Hinterkopf behalten, wenn wir jetzt drüber reden, es geht darum, mal zu erfahren, wie es eigentlich dazu kommt, dass uns in schöner Regelmäßigkeit, also fast wie so ein Zombie, so eine Gesetzgebung angeliefert wird, wo es irgendwie darum geht, dass das Internet nicht mehr alles kann, sondern irgendwie kontrolliert werden soll. Und um das zu verstehen, also dieses Frankensteinmonster und seinen Erstehungsprozess irgendwie nachvollziehen zu können, müssen wir uns jetzt mal mit der Struktur beschäftigen, also quasi mit den Werkzeugen, die der irre Wissenschaftler, der das Ding bastelt, immer zur Verfügung hat. Wer von euch macht das jetzt?
Ja, also ich glaube, wenn man verstehen möchte, wie die EU funktioniert, da kann man Bücher und Bücher drüber wälzen. Wer das mal ganz schnell nachlesen möchte, kann sich eigentlich das Booklet von EDRI runterladen. Das da heißt Activist's Guide to the Brussels Maze. Und das gibt es unter edri.org/papers.
Aber die besondere Herausforderung ist ja, dass du es uns jetzt so erklärst, dass wir es alle verstehen.
Okay, also es gibt quasi drei Institutionen in Brüssel. Das ist einmal die EU-Kommission, den Europäischen Rat, der sich aus den Mitgliedstaaten zusammensetzt und das EU-Parlament. Und die EU-Kommission, in der EU-Kommission gibt es wiederum 27 Kommissare, die quasi die EU-Minister sind hier. Und die sind alle für 33 Generaldirektionen zuständig. Also EU-Kommissarin für Justiz ist zum Beispiel Vivian Redding, für Digitale Agenda ist Nelly Kröss zuständig und Inneres macht halt Cecilia.
Inneres ist dann wirklich vergleichbar mit unserem Innenminister oder?
Vor kurzem war es vor ein paar Jahren noch zusammen mit Justiz und Inneres. Und seit 2009 gibt es eine eigene Kommissarin für Justiz.
So, und in diesem Geflecht, das sind die Basics der EU, also die grundlegenden Säulen, wie da Politik gemacht wird. Und wir haben jetzt schon über die Unterschiede zwischen ACTA und CleanIT gesprochen. Gehen wir mal zurück zur ACTA. Welchen Weg hat das durch diese drei Instanzen genommen?
Also ACTA wurde hauptsächlich von der Generaldirektion Trade, also Handel, verhandelt. Und ja, als der Text dann irgendwann fertig war, der wurde ja ziemlich lange geheim gehalten, dann ging er ins Europaparlament, wo sich dann die verschiedenen Ausschüsse damit auseinandergesetzt haben und darüber abstimmen konnten. Und dann schließlich ist es im EU-Parlament ins Plenum gegangen und alle Mitglieder des europäischen Parlaments konnten abstimmen. Ja, CleanIT ist nochmal was ganz anderes. Also wie André das eben schon erklärt hat, ist es ja lediglich ein Projekt, das von der Generaldirektion Inneres gefördert wurde.
Das heißt aber, das hört sich für mich so an, das kann ja schon ganz schön krasse Auswirkungen haben, aber es kann wirklich komplett an allen drei Säulen, die die EU hat sozusagen, vorbei in unsere Wirklichkeit schwappen.
Ja, das ist wie, wenn hier in Deutschland der Polizeipräsident mit einem Chef von Telekommunikationsunternehmen Abend ist und dann sagt, ich hätte gerne mal diese AGB-Änderung. Wir in Deutschland sind in der glücklichen Position, was ich vorhin schon mal angemerkt habe, diese Debatte um Internetsperren schon einmal durchgeforten zu haben. Das ist leider im Rest der EU nicht immer so gelaufen. Wir haben jetzt einmal Flöcke eingerammt, um zu sagen, wenn es irgendwas Illegales im Internets gibt, dann muss man da hingehen, den Server mitnehmen, dass das, gucken, dass das Zeug nicht mehr im Internet erreichbar ist und dann irgendwie forensisch analysieren, wer das dahin gemacht hat und eventuell Strafverfolgung einleiten.
Also kurz zusammengefasst, ein Verbrechen passiert, wir klären das auf.
So ungefähr. Und in dieser ganzen Zensursula-Debatte, die wir damals hatten, haben wir ja genau das gesehen. Unsere damalige Ministerin, auch heute immer noch Ministerin, nur in einem anderen Ressort, ist hingegangen und hat gedacht, so ich mache jetzt einen Vertrag mit der Telekom und da steht drin, die sollen bestimmte Webseiten sperren. Sie hat quasi genau das vorgeschlagen, was CleanIT von außen vorschlägt, hat sie als Ministerin damals vorgeschlagen. In der EU ist das ein bisschen komplizierter. Es gibt einen Haufen Diskussionsgremien. Eins ist CleanIT, was Kohle von dem DG Home, was dem Innenministerium bekommen hat. Aber es gibt gleichzeitig auch noch die CEO-Koalition for Better, Safer Internet for Children, die wieder DG Connect, glaube ich, finanziert hat. Gleichzeitig gibt es aber auch noch eine Umfrage bzw. wie die Kommission als Ganzes überhaupt mit dem Verfahren illegaler Inhalte im Internet zu Notice and Take Down umgehen will. Da weiß die eine Hand nicht immer, was die andere macht und die ziehen nicht immer koordiniert am selben Strang.
Warum machen die das?
Na, das geklärt immer nur so ein paar Themen, bei denen man sich nicht erklären muss, wenn man damit auf den Tisch haut. Da denkt endlich mal jemand an die armen Kinder, da denkt jemand mal daran, dass der Terrorismus eigentlich die Luft sprengt und da denkt jemand an die Nazis, die ihre Hasspropaganda im Internet verbreiten. Und da denkt man an den Stammtischen kommt der Dude an. Und ein Politiker hat ja dann auf so mittelfristige Sicht doch auch so die Wiederwahl im Auge und will dann einfach damit so Themen besetzen, die er für so Elfmeter-Themen hält. Und deswegen kommen die auch immer wieder als ich kann der Bevölkerung vermitteln, ich tue mal was und am Ende kostet mich das nicht viel und wenn ich die Kosten externalisieren kann, dann mache ich mir damit einen schönen Namen und jemand anderes hat den Ärger.
Also die Kosten externalisieren im Sinne von ich mache mal den Vorschlag, aber dann sagen, um das Ausbaden und den Rest könnte ich dann sozusagen so...
Die SPs kommen zum Beispiel.
Ja genau oder Leute, die dafür Geld kriegen mal so einen abstrosen Vorschlag zu machen. Jetzt haben wir schon gehört, also Frau Malström, also die Frau, deren Kommission dieses Klinitieprojekt eigentlich finanziert hat, will damit gar nichts mehr zu tun haben. Kirsten, wie ist das in Brüssel? Wie muss man jetzt eigentlich vorstellen? EDRI, also sagen als Lobbyorganisation, als Vertreter von Bürgerrechtsorganisationen vor Ort am EU-Regierungssitz, kriegt ihr dann so eine Stimmung intern mit oder lauft ihr dann einfach los und macht Lobbyarbeit im Sinne von, dass ihr sagt, wir wissen, es gibt diese Klinitie und das ist voll doof?
Das kommt ganz drauf an, um was es geht. Es gibt die ganz unterschiedlichsten Arten von Lobbyismus. Bei uns heißt es natürlich auch nicht Lobbying, sondern Advocacy, was wir machen. Ja, also bei uns geht es halt nicht um den Profit. Wir vertreten den Chaos Computer Club, wir vertreten die digitale Gesellschaft oder die Open Rights Group. Und bei uns sieht das dann so aus, dass wir zu den verschiedenen Anhörungen oder Konferenzen laufen. Meistens werden wir eingeladen, in Ausschüssen im Europaparlament zu sprechen oder halt bei Expertengruppen in der Kommission mitzumachen, wie zum Beispiel zu RFID oder dem Internet der Dinger jetzt. Und auch in der Expertengruppe zu Notice and Take Down waren wir mit dabei.
Notice and Take Down ist diese Idee davon, wenn man was Böses im Internet macht, kriegt man einen Brief und das wird dann irgendwie runtergenommen.
EDRI wurde ja auch zu Clean IT eingeladen, oder?
Ja, also das Ganze hat natürlich eine längere Hintergrundgeschichte. Also irgendwie wurden wir da auch über Twitter und keine Ahnung, was schon ein bisschen kritisiert, weil wir nicht mitgemacht haben. Aber dazu muss man halt wissen, dass wir uns seit 2010 quasi mit den Leuten, die das Projekt machen wollen, im Kreis gedreht haben. Also wir haben 2010 zusammen mit der EuroISPA, also den Internet Service Providern hier und auch ITNO, ein Schreiben aufgesetzt und aufgelistet, was alles gewährleistet sein muss, damit Projekte halt nicht Grundrechte verletzen. Und die hörten uns dann geduldig zu. Und am Ende eines Meetings stand dann der Projektleiter, der jetzige Projektleiter des CleanITs auf und kündigte dann an, das CleanIT Projekt starten zu wollen. Und dann ging das Ganze halt wieder von vorne los. Und ja, dann haben wir einen kurzen E-Mail-Austausch mit ihm dargelegt, was unsere Forderungen sind. Also erstmal, dass das Problem überhaupt definiert werden soll, was da gelöst werden soll. Und das hat er dann alles abgelehnt. Und daraufhin haben wir dann unsere Teilnahme abgesagt.
Ihr habt also da gar nicht erstmal mitgemacht, aber jetzt ist ja dieses Papier an die Öffentlichkeit gebracht. Wie sieht dann eure Arbeit aus? Also was habt ihr dann seitdem gemacht? Außer dass du jetzt hier im Chaosradio bist und nochmal genau erzählst, wie die Sache abläuft.
Ja, also seitdem haben wir das Ding an die Presse getragen und mein Kollege Joe hat ganz viele Interviews schon gegeben dazu. Und ja.
Aber wie sieht das denn aus? Also arbeitet ihr denn gar nicht so sagen mit den Parlamentariern selber zusammen, sondern seid ihr die Organisation, die das nach außen trägt zu den anderen Leuten?
Ja, in diesem Fall halt schon. In diesem Fall schon, weil Clean IT ja kein Projekt ist oder kein Gesetzesvorschlag ist in dem Sinne und daher auch nicht durchs EU-Parlament gehen wird. Also wenn das jetzt im Falle von ACTA haben wir uns schon mit Europa-Parlamentariern getroffen und dann genau erklärt, worum es geht und auf was sie halt aufpassen sollen.
Aber ich hätte gedacht, dass man in so einem Fall dann sozusagen zumindest versucht, dass die Politiker Druck ausüben, dass so ein Vertrag gar nicht erst geschlossen wird. Oder geht das nicht?
Ja, das ist jetzt, jetzt ist das Kind in den Brunnen gefallen. Also das Geld wurde vor zwei Jahren bewilligt und wie bei so vielen Problemen und Policy-Problemen, die das Internet betreffen, erfahren wir oft erst hinterher, was denn da eigentlich ist für Gremien gibt, die sich Sachen ausdenken und müssen dann reagieren. Ganz am Anfang, also es gibt keinen Parlamentarier, der dieses Projekt auf dem Schirm hatte, vielleicht ein paar einzelne Mitarbeiter in der Kommission, aber das ist jetzt nicht wie bei ACTA, wo man eben dann hingehen konnte und das Parlament die Verantwortung hatte, ACTA anzunehmen, zu ändern oder in die Papiertonne zu treten, dass man dann hingehen konnte und sagt, hey ACTA lehnen wir ab und zwar aus folgenden Gründen, bei CleanIT, das interessiert bisher noch kein Parlamentarier, außer jetzt mit der Medienaufmerksamkeit. Die meisten haben auch davon von diesem EDRI-Leak gehört.
Aber was passiert dann bei den Parlamentariern?
Also wenn bei uns der Vorsitzende der Gewerkschaft, der Polizei mal wieder einen Internet-Not-Ausknopf fordert, dann kann sich da vielleicht irgendein Hinterbänkler, der CSU-befleißig kühlen, das noch mal nach vorne zu tragen, weil das eine tolle Idee hält. Aber mich würde im Vergleich mal interessieren, war das jetzt so ein Schnäppchen? Also ich meine, so eine Schnapsidee, die dann da finanziert worden ist mit von der EU, aber war das im Vergleich, haben wir diese Schnapsidee billig bekommen, oder war das schon, dass man sich am Kopf schlagen muss, wie viel Geld sie da versenkt haben?
Also ich bin jetzt auch nicht der Experte drin, aber 400.000 Euro sind jetzt für so ein Projekt, was irgendwie in sechs, sieben Sitzungen quer durch Europakonferenzen organisiert und Leute einfliegt, nicht so die Mega-Kohle. Wenn wir vielleicht mal ein anderes recht bekanntes Forschungsprojekt der EU, was auch Wellen geschlagen hat, heranziehen, INDECT, ich habe den Namen vergessen, was das ausgesprochen heißt, aber auch so ein Forschungsprojekt, was man in alles machen könnte, an Überwachungssensorik und die Stadt der Zukunft und Überwachungskameras und so weiter und so fort. Das hat einige Millionen Euro bekommen und ist dann an Unis gegangen.
Das war aber dann auch so einmal, dass eine komplette Stadt einmal komplett Video überwacht und diese Informationen zusammenfühlen und sämtliche Bürger versuchen auch zu erkennen und dort mit EU-Kohle finanziert einmal ein Citizen Tracking zu machen.
Genau, das war ein bisschen größer. Da haben wir aber einen schönen Vergleich zwischen den beiden Projekten. Sowohl CleanIT als auch INDECT sind jetzt in der Öffentlichkeit ein bisschen bekannt. Und kriegen zu Recht Schelte ab, weil die aus vielen verschiedenen Punkten zu kritisieren sind, was wir jetzt hier im Radio auch machen. Aber beide sind nur die hellen Leuchttürme von dem eigentlichen Grundproblem, nämlich jede einzelne Maßnahme, die in diesem Horrorkatalog von CleanIT steht oder auch viele der Ansätze von INDECT sind an sich heraus zu kritisieren. Und nicht nur, wenn sie geballt im Gesamtprojekt ankommen, wo man schön die Reihen schließen kann, wo jeder nur dagegen sein kann, der sich irgendwie mit Internet- oder Überwachungspolitik beschäftigt. Das Problem ist, bei diesen Projekten auf INDECT haben sich viele Leute darauf eingeschlagen und Aktivismus dagegen organisiert. Hintenrum passieren dann aber ähnliche Forschungsprojekte, die leider nicht ganz so viel Aufmerksamkeit bekommen. Diesen Fehler müssen wir jetzt bei CleanIT versuchen zu vermeiden, sondern die Politik angreifen und nicht nur das einzelne Projekt.
Okay, ich würde sagen, dass ich zu dem großen Hintergrund, zu dem großen Blick hinter die Kulissen gleich komme. Jetzt hat hier im Chat gerade jemand gefragt, also es gingen immer so viele Fragen, die ich jetzt gestellt habe, zu wer macht das, warum, weshalb, wann, konnten nicht beantwortet werden, weil ihr die Informationen nicht habt und im Chat fragt gerade jemand, naja, ihr habt ja auch nicht mitgearbeitet bei dem Projekt, dann müsst ihr euch nicht bewundern, dass ihr keine Informationen kriegt. Ja, aber die Beratenden sagen es ja auch nicht in der Schweiz, aber ihr könnt euch da Schnittchen und Rinsept ausgeben. Kirsten, ich hätte gerne noch mal zwei Punkte von dir erklärt bekommen. Der eine ist, warum ihr euch sozusagen geweigert habt, damit zu arbeiten und der andere ist, ob euch das tatsächlich, diesen von dem Vanades heißt es in dem Chat, vermutungst stimmt, dass ihr einen Informationsvorteil gehabt hättet, wenn ihr damit gemacht hättet.
Also den Informationsvorteil beantworte ich das schon mal, glaube ich, nicht. Und warum wir uns geweigert haben, das habe ich ja eben schon mal versucht zu erklären, weil wir uns da einfach mit dem Projektleiter im Kreis gedreht haben. Also wir haben ganz klar erklärt, dass wir bei keinem Projekt mitmachen können, wo noch nichtmals das Problem definiert ist.
Also das ist dann auch im Prinzip so eine Frage, wo man an der eigenen Glaubwürdigkeit verliert, wenn man sagt, okay, wir machen da jetzt mit.
Ja und es ist auch Zeitverschwendung. EDRI sind drei Leute, die für uns in Brüssel arbeiten und es gibt so viele schlechte Internetpolitik, die beobachtet werden möchte, dass man sich schon überlegt, wo man seine Energie reinsteht. Ich habe jetzt noch mal die Punkte, die wir gestern auf Netzpolitik auch noch mal gebracht haben, die Joe gepostet haben vor mir. Also man hätte durchaus mit Clean IT geredet, wenn denn ein paar Basisbanalitäten eingehalten wären. Einer hat Kirsten schon angesprochen, was ist überhaupt das Problem? Was ist Terrorismus im Internet? Soll das jetzt wirklich irgendwie Al-Qaeda-Netzwerke sein oder die terroristische und extremistische Nutzung des Internets oder irgendwie illegale Software? Im Laufe des Verfahrens sind alle Sachen mal aufgeworfen worden und nichts ist so richtig greifbar. Was denn überhaupt das Problem ist? Ein zweiter Punkt ist, irgendwie man wollte die Internetindustrie beteiligen und in einem Dokument, das wir schon im Februar veröffentlicht haben, war dann so eine Auflistung aller Firmen zu haben, die irgendwas mit Internet zu tun zu haben, also irgendwie der Maushersteller und der Routerhersteller bis hin zu Zertifikatausgebern, sozialen Netzwerken, das ist nicht glaubwürdig oder wirksam, so eine Riesenliste aufzusetzen. Also welches Problem möchte man mit welchen Akteuren am Tisch eigentlich lösen? Und das dritte Problem ist, solche Forschungsprojekte können ja gerne mal frei denken, aber dazu müssen Grundregeln eingehalten werden und das sind klar in der Europäischen Union und in dem System, in dem wir leben, gelten Grundrechte, eine Grundrechtecharte und das muss sichergestellt werden bei allen Projekten, dass das keine unabsichtliche Folgen hat und schon gar nicht irgendwie Grundrechte ohne Gesetzesbeschluss hinten durch verletzt werden. Und das sind Bedingungen, die EDRI an CleanIT gestellt hat, wobei CleanIT gesagt hat, ne, das können wir euch nicht garantieren, wir wollen jetzt einfach mal drüber reden.
Jetzt hat sich ja die Frau Malmström, also die Vorsitzende der Kommission, die das dann letztendlich finanziert hat, schon dagegen ausgesprochen, habt ihr erzählt, ganz toll. Glaubt ihr denn, dass das Ding irgendwie, also jetzt das konkrete Ding über die Nach- und Vorwählen, reden wir gleich nochmal, so konkret irgendwie tatsächlich nochmal Anwendung findet oder ist die Aufregung jetzt schon so groß, dass es eigentlich gar nicht mehr geht?
Ja, also ich glaube, dass CleanIT nicht mehr viel bringen wird. Also anfangs war es ja noch ein Projekt, jetzt ist es nur noch eine Brainstorming-Session. Also ich glaube nicht mehr, dass da noch viel kommt.
Ja, die Europäische Union hat mal eine halbe Million Euro auszugeben, um ein paar Stichpunkte zu haben mit schlechter Internetpolitik, die man jetzt in den Papierkorb werfen muss.
Meine Güte, vielleicht sollte ich meinen Beruf wechseln und auch irgendwie schlechte Internetpolitik machen. Es scheint sich sehr zu lohnen. Jetzt stellt ihr euch möglicherweise die Frage, Entschuldigt mal, ihr habt mir jetzt eine Stunde in den Ohr abgekaut, mir EU-Politik erklärt, weil es da ein Projekt gibt, das sowieso nichts wird. Warum zur Hölle? Ganz einfach. Das Ding ist nur ein weiterer Schritt. Es gibt sozusagen immer wieder, zwei Namen sind schon gefallen, Akta und Indic, es gibt immer wieder die Versuche, sozusagen diese Art von Politik zu machen, nämlich das, was manche Leute als Freiheit bezeichnen, einzuschränken, um so einen Sicherheitsgewinn versprechen zu können. Wo das herkommt und warum das immer wieder gemacht wird, darüber möchte ich gleich noch genauer sprechen. Oral vom Binär-Pilot hier im Chaosradio auf Fritz im Blue Moon, wo es heute um europäische Politik geht. Hört es erstmal groß an, ist aber sozusagen ganz einfach und runtergebrochen auf ein Projekt, das Clean IT heißt und wo es um die Einschränkung von Internetsachen geht. Wir haben das von der letzten Stunde genauer besprochen und haben festgestellt, okay, das ist halt so ein Ding, das haben sich Leute ausgedacht, die dafür auch viel Geld bekommen haben, für so 400.000, um mal zu sagen, wir möchten eigentlich das ganze Internet verbieten und sprechen darüber heute mit Erdgeist vom CCC, Ilf vom CCC, Hallihallo und Kirsten Fiedler von EDRI und mit Andre Meister von Netzpolitik. Wir haben das jetzt im Speziellen besprochen und möchten das jetzt ein bisschen ausweiten, um dann letztendlich nach dem Ende dieser Sendung heute verstehen zu können, warum diese Art und Weise von Gesetze immer wieder kommt und was jetzt eigentlich Brüssel damit zu tun hat. Und dazu möchte ich erstmal noch eine Sache fragen, die bezieht sich fast schon persönlich auf dich, Kirsten. EDRI ist also, haben wir schon gehört, eine Lobby-Organisation, die also Bürgerrechtsorganisationen in Brüssel verdrückt hat? Drei Leute?
Ja.
Das ist nicht besonders viel. Was sind das für Leute und was genau macht ihr da?
Also, erstmal ist hier Joe, unser Geschäftsführer. Der hat das bis vor einem Jahr noch ganz alleine geschmissen, hier den Laden. Und im letzten September sind halt dann noch Marie und ich hinzugekommen. Und ja, wir stehen kurz vor dem Umzug. Also wir hoffen, dass wir ein bisschen größer werden können jetzt in der nächsten Zeit, weil wir wirklich in Arbeit hier untergehen. Also das ist nicht nur CleanIT, das sind noch ganz viele andere schöne Projekte. Und wie ich am Anfang schon mal erklärt habe, machen wir ja nicht nur, beobachten wir ja nicht nur so komische Projekte wie CleanIT, sondern auch machen auch Urheberrecht, Datenschutz, Vorratsdatenspeicherung, alles Mögliche.
Also das sozusagen, was man hier in Deutschland möglicherweise als Internetaktivismus bezeichnen würde. Aber kannst du konkret sagen, wie sieht so ein Arbeitstag von dir aus? Also vielleicht, was hast du heute gemacht?
Heute immer anders. Also jeder Tag ist wirklich anders. Manchmal laufen wir halt in Anhörungen im europäischen Parlament und schreiben alles mit und teilen das dann, was hier so abläuft, unseren Mitgliedern, unseren nationalen Mitgliedern mit. Und manchmal treffen wir uns ganz persönlich mit Abgeordneten oder aber auch Kommissionsvertretern.
Jetzt gibt es da sozusagen Politiker, mit denen ihr redet oder wo ihr hört, was die sagen. Aber ihr seid ja wahrscheinlich nicht die Einzigen, die ihr nennt, das ist Advocacy. Die anderen machen dann Lobbyarbeit betreiben.
Was gibt es da noch für Leute in Brüssel? Das Problem, das das EDRI hat, ist, dass wir schon seit sehr langer Zeit die einzige netzpolitische Organisation hier in Brüssel sind. Das ändert sich jetzt so langsam. Wenn man allein die ganzen Lobbyisten aus der Unterhaltungsindustrie zusammenrechnet, kommt man auf mehrere hunderte. Bei der Sicherheitsindustrie sind das bestimmt noch mehr. Die haben natürlich auch ganz andere finanzielle Mittel.
Brüssel, ist das so eine Stadt, in die es dich eh verschlagen hätte? Oder musstest du da sehr bewusst hingehen? Hat das irgendwie mehr Gründe, so jetzt in die EU-Stadt da hinzugehen? Oder für den Autonormaleuro-Politiker hätte der dann auch in Brüssel etwas anderes machen können? Oder kann man sich das schwer vorstellen? Ist es eine schöne Stadt oder ist es irgendwie noch anders spannend?
Also ich glaube, das ist ganz objektiv. Also ich finde Brüssel super, weil es wirklich total multikulturell hier ist. Also nicht nur durch die Brussels-Bubble, wie wir das nennen. Ich glaube, andere finden Brüssel nicht so schön, weil es hier ziemlich viel regnet. Aber ja, ich wollte halt, also ich habe vorher im Süden Europas gewohnt und wollte halt einfach wieder in den Norden hoch.
Okay, wenn man in Brüssel ist, merkt man, dass das wie weiß eigentlich Berlin ist von den Leuten. In Brüssel gibt es Schokolade, Bier und Pommes. Das ist auch noch eine Attraktion neben der ganz hübschen Innenstadt. Aber die meisten Lobbyisten sind tatsächlich in dieser Bubble, in diesem Europaviertel. Das sind aber nicht andere, großartig andere Politiker, als die, die es auch nach Berlin in den Bundestag verschlägt, von ihren Landkreisen über ganz Deutschland. Die sind dann eben nur aus ganz Europa. Aber da sind auch die unterschiedlichsten Menschen dabei, je nach Partei und je nach Interessenslage.
Aber trotzdem gibt es ja immer wieder diese Vorschläge, Projekte, Initiativen, was auch immer, die mit dem, was ihr wahrscheinlich in Beschneidung des Internets zu tun haben. Was ist denn das für ein Schlag von Menschen, der in Brüssel arbeitet? Was ist denn das für ein Beet, in dem man immer wieder geboren wird? Woran liegt das?
Ich glaube, das ist nicht auf Brüssel begrenzt. Wenn die deutsche Polizeigewerkschaft sowas sagt, dann sagen wir ja auch nicht, das ist im Internet geboren oder in Deutschland geboren.
Aber es ist ja schon so, Vorratsdatenspeicherung haben wir dann mal hier abgeklärt.
Das ist immer ein guter Punkt, dass du die Vorratsdatenspeicherung erwähnst, weil das war ja damals das erste Mal, dass wir da von der EU auch kalt erwischt worden sind. Da gab es hier so ein paar Sicherheitspolitiker, die es nicht geschafft haben, das Vorratsdatenspeicherungsäquivalent dort im Telekommunikationsgesetz unterzubringen, weil der Bundesrat gesagt hat, spinnst du? Und daraufhin wurde dann dieser europäische Umweg beschritten und die Vorratsdatenspeicherung als Richtlinie der EU verabschiedet. Und Deutschland sollte das implementieren. Und dann kam plötzlich Vorratsdatenspeicherung als deutsches Gesetz und wurde vom Verfassungsgericht kassiert. Und ja, der Hacker-Szene und digitalen Szene ist es damals echt übel aufgestoßen. Und dort ist dann auch das Bewusstsein geschärft worden, dass wir da mal gucken müssen, wenn die EU irgendwas bestimmen kann, was Deutschland umsetzen muss, was aber unseren Interessen wirklich konträr entgegenläuft, dann muss man da vielleicht schon vorher ansetzen. Und das war auch dann im Club die Initialzündung, um EDRI unterstützen zu wollen.
Ja, also bei allen Sachen, die wir heute besprochen haben, weil ich meine natürlich Herr Weiser, aber das hat ja schon so den Eindruck, als ob das sozusagen in Brüssel alles seinen Anfang findet.
Nö, das findet den Anfang nur, weil es halt bequemer ist. Ich meine, so einfach an einer zentralen Stelle Gesetze zu erlassen, um sich dann einfach im nationalen Parlament nicht mehr darum kümmern zu müssen, ob das so mit den Grundrechten vereinbar ist, ist doch dann deutlich bequemer.
Ja, aber die Sache ist ja die Sache, was ich sozusagen von außen erlebe, ist folgendes. In der EU wird genau immer so ein Gesetz ausgebracht, genau aus dem Grund, weil wenn man es da macht, dann hat man es gleich für alle EU-Staaten, schon einfach. Aber es fällt dann immer auch auf mehr oder weniger fruchtbaren Boden, nicht fruchtigen. Und es sieht für mich aus, als würde ich sagen, es gibt immer diese langen, langen, langen Kämpfe von Aktivisten, die sozusagen dagegen vorgehen und irgendwie Leute auf die Straße ziehen und Politiker beklien und dann so nach langem wirklich elend langen Zerren, dann wird so ein Ding mal wieder beerdigt und bam, drei Monate später kommt das nächste. Das ist sozusagen, das ist ja, da würde ich schon sagen, da läuft was falsch im Staat Brüssel.
Ja, ich glaube also, dass das Clean IT, dass das Problem ist, dass das halt nur ein Symptom eines allgemeinen Trends ist. Also schon seit einigen Jahren versuchen halt EU-Kommissionen, aber auch Mitgliedstaaten, US-Regierungen, sogar OECD immer wieder durch die verschiedensten Projekte halt Unternehmen irgendwie zu Polizeirichter und Henker gleichzeitig im Internet zu machen. Und genauso gibt es jetzt auch zwei weitere Projekte, die ähnlich ist wie Clean IT planen. Also das sind einmal, Andre hat es eben schon erwähnt, die CEO-Collision und die ICT-Collision.
CEO haben wir schon gehört, da geht es um Kinderschutz vorgeblich. Was war das andere?
Genau, ICT-Collision ist so ähnlich wie die CEO-Collision, aber irgendwie auch noch was anderes. Und da geht es auch um Kinder- und Jugendschutz. Irgendwie muss man mal was machen, damit unsere Kinder sicherer sind. Und da hat sich die Kommission halt auch verschiedene Industriepartner zusammen gerufen.
Der Trend der Privatisierung, der Rechtsvorsetzung, den sehen wir tatsächlich in immer kürzeren Abständen immer häufiger auch in der EU, aber auch in Deutschland. Ich meine, habe vorhin die Debatte schon mal angesprochen, die Debatte um Zensursula und die Netzsperren gegen Internetpornografie, das war ein Vorschlag aus Deutschland. Den mussten wir hier bekämpfen. Das war auch Privatisierung der Rechtsvorsetzung. Ein Ministerium wollte einen Vertrag mit Providern machen und die sollten Seiten sperren, auch ganz ohne Gesetz. Jetzt haben wir verschiedene Initiativen von Two, Three Strikes oder was sich die Contentindustrie da gerne wünscht, dass Provider ihre Nutze überwachen sollen und dann denen irgendwelche Warnhinweise schicken sollen. Das sind alles Symptome der Bekämpfung der Verlagerung der Rechtsvorsetzung auf private Unternehmen, die wir in Brüssel sehen, die wir aber auch genauso in Berlin sehen.
Würde ich halt sagen, also als Effizientdenken, Aktivistdenken, so ja okay, das kommt jetzt immer wieder. Lass uns doch mal die Wurzel des Übels finden und die einfach ausrotten.
Also die Wurzel des Übels erstmal zu benennen ist, glaube ich, wenn man da versucht ein Muster zu erkennen, ist mir jetzt just die Woche der Juristentag in Bayern. Die haben da irgendwie auch Dinge gefordert, die stehen da in Clean IT mit auch drinnen. Die wollten keinen anonymen Zugang mehr zum Internet, damit die Rechtsdurchsetzung allumfassend ist. Da muss man jetzt noch mal ganz kurz sich vergegenwärtigen. Die wollen einfach aus einer Fachidioten Blickrichtung einfach mal die Werkzeuge, die ihnen da Techniker, die genauso Fachidioten sind, erklärt haben. Es geht alles. Wir können dort plötzlich dieses Internet können wir, wir müssen nur ein bisschen hier an dem Algorithmus, da an dem Algorithmus, da kriegen wir total sicher. Und die Juristen gucken, oh, wir können da irgendwie endlich mal dieses juristische Regelwerk, was im alltäglichen Leben so ein bisschen komplex ist, weil da sind immer Menschen und die verhalten sich da irgendwie nicht so richtig, wie man das vielleicht mit juristischen Algorithmen beschreiben kann. Und da kommen die zusammen und fühlen sich da plötzlich wie im Himmel. Also ich glaube, es ist eher so Fachidiotentum auf höchstem Niveau. Man kann endlich da seinen Steckenpferd der gesamten Gesellschaft überhelfen und kann dort dann mit den technischen Möglichkeiten mal durchsetzen, was im richtigen Leben, also in der Offline-Welt, nicht so leicht durchdrückbar ist.
Also ich muss insofern zumindest mal nachfragen, dass ich doch ein paar Juristen und ein paar Techniker kennen, die sich jetzt sozusagen also verwehren würden, über diesen Kamm geschoren zu werden. Also der Schluss wäre, dass du sagst, okay, alle Juristen sind Politiker. Und die kennen so viele Techniker und deswegen kommen immer diese Vorschläge oder wie?
Nein, sie haben da jetzt mal just entdeckt. Da gibt es dieses Internet und dann haben sie das.
Die haben das jetzt entdeckt?
Na ja, so das Bewusstsein dämmert so langsam. So gerade die Älteren, die sich ihre E-Mails nicht mehr abtippen lassen von ihrer Sekretärin. Die haben dann irgendwie plötzlich auch noch mitbekommen, dass da irgendwie noch, das ist ja ein weites Feld und da passieren auch ganz doll böse Dinge. Aber eigentlich kann man das nicht regulieren, das ist ja alles elektronisch. Und dann sagt dir jemand, ja, das geht. Und ich glaube, dass dort einfach dieser blinde Glaube an das System, an den Computer, dass man dort einfach elektronische Systeme zur effizienten Rechtsdurchsetzung benutzen kann, dass der Glaube einfach tief verankert ist inzwischen. Und das ist eins der Grundübel, dass dort am Ende der Menschen nur noch, ja, peripher vorkommt und reguliert und in Bahnen gelenkt werden muss.
Kirsten, ist das denn bei euch dann so, dass ihr immer nur auf die Symptome gehen könnt? Also sozusagen, da kommt der nächste schlimme Vorschlag, da müssen wir jetzt wieder was machen und mal wieder mit den Politikern reden, um ihnen zu erklären, wie es wirklich ist. Oder kann man auch so eine Art Profilaxe bei Politikern betreiben und zu sagen, diesen Grundsatz, nämlich man will eigentlich kein kontrolliertes Internet irgendwie den nahe bringen?
Ganz viele Fragen in einem Satz. Ja, also ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich anfangen soll. Also wir arbeiten schon seit mehreren Jahren an diesem Problem der privatisierten Rechtsdurchsetzung und haben 2010 auch eine Studie dazu rausgegeben, die müssen wir eigentlich mal bearbeiten. Und ja, ich glaube, dass wir hier noch viel mehr Aufklärungsarbeit bei den Politikern einfach machen müssen. Also zum Beispiel die konservative EVP, also die Europäische Volkspartei, hier im Europaparlament hat das Internet wirklich erst im November letzten Jahres entdeckt und ihr Internetstrategiepapier veröffentlicht.
Aua, ich glaube auch, das ist eher das Problem, schon mal kurz den Sozialwissenschaftler heraushängen lassen. In unserer modernen Gesellschaft haben wir viele verschiedene Leute, die ihre ganz eigenen Zugänge zu verschiedenen politischen Themen finden. Und wir alle, die mit dem Internet aufgewachsen sind und es als völlig normalen Teil unseres Lebensalltags betrachten, wir sehen da die unglaublichen Möglichkeiten und die Chancen, wir nutzen das ganz selbstverständlich, ab und zu könnte mal ein Problem auftauchen, aber das kann man irgendwie auch lösen. Wenn man jetzt aber irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, Politiker ist oder auch ein normaler Durchschnittsdeutscher, der ja langsam auf die Rente zugeht, noch nie großartig was mit diesem Internet zu tun gehabt hat, aber dann im Fernsehen hört, dass das alles ganz schlimm ist und dass sich da die Raubkopier-Mörder-Terroristen-Kinderschänder tummeln, dann muss man was dagegen tun. Und ob Brüssel oder Berlin, manche Politiker in den eher konservativen Parteien oder die nicht ganz so das Internet in den Lebensalltag aufgenommen haben, die tendieren dann eher dazu, die Probleme zu sehen als die Chancen und kommen dann teilweise auch mit Sachen, die wenn man eine Ahnung vom Internet hat und die durchdenkt, nur zu dem Schluss kommen kann, haben die sie nach alle.
Aber ist das denn nicht ein bisschen zu kurz gegriffen? Also so wie du es gerade erzählt hast, heißt es ja sagen, es gibt eine junge Generation, die kennt das Internet, es gibt eine alte Generation, die kennt das nicht. Ich werde dir die Behauptung aufstellen, dass es durchaus Leute gibt, also in eurer Generation, auch die das Internet sehr wohl kennen, die aber trotzdem das mit der Sicherheit ist eine super Idee.
Ich wollte mich auch nicht auf die Generationenfrage beschränken, sondern natürlich haben wir auch verschiedene Ausprägungen von Weltbildern in unserer Gesellschaft. Und wenn ich jetzt in der CSU bin und den ganzen Tag den Mümmelmann als Terroristen vor mir als Feindbild sehe, dann habe ich einen anderen Zugang zu dem Thema Terrorismus im Internet als die Leute, die den ganzen Tag das Internet ganz selbstverständlich nutzen und produktiv damit sind.
Obwohl, wir können das auch nicht wirklich über einen Kamm scheren, also hier im Europaparlament gibt es schon einige Abgeordnete, die sich sehr gut auskennen und da sind alle Generationen mit dabei und das sind Abgeordnete aus allen Parteien.
Wird das Problem dann jemals geklärt oder ist das dann so eine Art Syphosarbeit, man rollt den Stein der Internetfreiheit immer wieder den Berg hoch?
Ich glaube, dass es am Ende ein Abwägen von Interessen ist. Totale Freiheit führt am Ende vielleicht auch zu einem Missbrauch dieser Freiheiten. Natürlich muss man Extrempositionen versuchen zu verteidigen, um sich dann irgendwann in einem gesellschaftlichen Konsens wiederzufinden. Aber dass der Stein immer wieder den Berg runterfällt in letzter Zeit sehe ich nicht so. Wir haben Flöcke eingerammt, hinter die einfach nicht mehr zurückgegangen werden kann. Und dieses CleanIT-Projekt mit den Forderungen, die jetzt dort auftauchen, da ist die Hälfte einfach schon komplett so lebensfremd, dass sich keiner mehr trauen würde, der ein Amt bekleidet oder gewählt wurde, die dann öffentlich zu wiederholen. Und wir sollten einfach versuchen, Steine hochrollen und mit der neuen Pfahl einrahmen und so weiter.
Aber heißt das dann, was man sich sagen muss, eigentlich über dieses Ding keine Sorgen mehr machen muss, weil es eh noch Quatsch ist?
Und das CleanIT? Das war ja mein Eingangsstatement.
Ist es vielleicht noch ein kleiner Unterschied, möchte ich vielleicht fragen?
Ich glaube, dass das Papier an sich nützlich für uns ist, um zu sehen, was da gerade noch die Themen auf der Agenda sind. Weil die werden ja auch gegoogelt haben, um zu gucken, was man da gerade noch als Begründung anführen kann. Haben uns damit die Arbeit gespart. Aber ansonsten wird es natürlich immer wieder Leute geben, die automatisierte Rechtsdurchsetzung, dieses Automatic Policing, ist eigentlich ein großes Thema für die Zukunft. Was dann passiert, was mit einer Gesellschaft passiert, wenn du es schaffst, sämtliche Handlungen einer Person automatisch zu bestrafen, zu was für einer Normierung das führt. Wie auch eine automatisierte Rechtsdurchsetzung, die auch von irgendwelchen privaten Firmen dann ohne jegliche Abwägung durchgeführt wird, die die Verhältnismäßigkeit dann nicht beachten. Man stelle sich halt nur vor, wenn einfach die Gesellschaft keinerlei Spielraum mehr gibt, dann wäre die gesamte Schwulenbewegung heute komplett nicht existenz, weil er war ja illegal. Und erst weil diese Leute dann durch an die Öffentlichkeit treten, illegale Dinge zu propagieren, den gesellschaftlichen Konsens verschoben haben, war es erst möglich, dass sich die Gesellschaft weiterentwickelt hat. Und deswegen müssen wir natürlich als eine demokratischen, freie Gesellschaft immer noch immer weiter dafür kämpfen, dass nicht Maschinen am Ende darüber entscheiden, in automatisierten Algorithmen, wie wir uns verhalten und dann de facto außerhalb des Gesetzes noch mal ein ganz eigenes Gesetz schaffen. Weil was nämlich passiert, wenn Firmen in ihren AGBs oder in ihren automatischen Filtern bestimmen können, was im Internet passiert und was nicht, dass ein ziemlich signifikanter Bereich des Lebens automatisiert poliest wird. Genau, kontrolliert wird.
Jetzt, ich muss zu einer Sache zurückkommen, die du gerade gesagt hast, das ist nämlich die mit den Maximalforderungen. Du sagst es selber gerade, dass man so macht. Man stellt dann erstmal eine Extremforderung und dann trifft man sich irgendwo in der Mitte. Könnte man also auch sagen, diese ganzen Sicherheitsforderungen sind eigentlich auch nur, weil die andere Seite das genauso macht, sind auch nur so Extremforderungen, die sozusagen den Beginn des Falschens markieren und dann trifft man sich irgendwo. Also die wollen das eigentlich auch gar nicht so hart?
Na dafür war es dann aber echt schlecht abgeguckt.
Und ich glaube, dass wirklich professionelle Politiker das schon ein bisschen subtiler gemacht hätten und das Ganze irgendwie in Worten irgendwo, in irgendwelchen Gesetzestexten noch untergeschoben hätten, also dass dieses CleanIT Projekt, das war wirklich eine Sache von Amateuren.
Okay, okay, lass mal einfach so zu sehen, aber ich würde jetzt sagen, ich würde dann noch mal vermuten, okay, sie machen das, dann hat man so das ganz Extrem abgesteckt und darüber gelacht. Und dann das nächste, was man bringt, ist dann sozusagen so 75 Prozent auf dem Weg zum Extrem. Man sagt so, okay, wir haben jetzt mal ernsthafte Vorschläge gemacht und dann müsste man darüber dann schon wieder ernsthaft reden. Aber eine andere Diskussion, die gerade hier im Chat losgetreten wird und der Herr ruft leider nicht an. Herrgott, 0331 70 97 111. Wir haben doch jetzt schon das Telefon. Bring das nochmal hier. Ich finde es aber ganz spannend, deswegen will ich das mal einfach hier hin übertragen. Er sagt, es wird zu wenig mit den Leuten geredet und da hat Ilf, der auch hier im Studio sitzt im Chat, gesagt, na ja, aber die EDRI hat doch gesagt, unter folgenden Voraussetzungen reden wir mit denen. Darum ging es ihm aber nicht, sondern er sagt, es wird allgemein zu wenig mit der anderen Seite kommuniziert, im Sinne von, dass man denen so ein bisschen pädagogisch was beibringt, habe ich das Gefühl. Und da gab es ja sozusagen, da gab es in Deutschland so ein Vorfall, der Herr Guttenberg, der uns allen gut bekannt ist, durch das Abschreiben seiner, oder was ist nicht Abschreiben, man weiß es nicht so genau, aber der ist ja jetzt, nachdem er Verteidigungsminister war, ist er jetzt für Internetfreiheit irgendwie da in der EU zugange und hat sich ja mit jemand getroffen, der Internetaktivistisch in Deutschland ist, nämlich Stefan Obach und davon gab es, da gab es halt viel Feuerwehr, allein für die Tatsache, dass die beiden miteinander reden. Ist das jetzt so, dass ihr als Aktivisten sagt, also es lohnt sich eigentlich gar nicht mit denen zu reden, weil das verschwendet liebes Mühe ist?
Na nicht nur, es gibt denen auch so eine gewisse Autorität noch dazu. Seht mal, wir trauen ihm da so viel Gravitas und so viel Einfluss in diesen Themen zu, dass es sich lohnt, sich mit ihm zusammenzusetzen. Also muss der ja da schon irgendeinen Peil von der Materie haben und das will man einfach so Leuten nicht entleben. Ich würde den Gutenberg jetzt nicht unterstellen, dass er sich mit Netzthemen so gut auskennt, dass er uns da in Europa vertreten würde. Und das hätte wahrscheinlich den Anstrich gehabt, wenn wir uns mit ihm hingesetzt haben. Und ich glaube nicht, dass er uns irgendwas Sinnvolles zu diesem Thema hätte erzählen können.
Naja, aber ihr ihm.
Und dann?
Naja, der hat ja diesen Posten jetzt. Meinst du, das ist wirklich nur so ein Geld-Einsack-Ding? Der hat da gar nichts zu melden? Also wäre das nicht die Chance gewesen, eine Idee dahin zu tragen?
Als ob der dort unsere Ideen vertreten würde.
Naja, also möglicherweise wahrscheinlich nicht, aber man weiß es ja nicht. So, Ilf schlägt gerade die Hände über dem Kopf zusammen und die platzt gleich. Was ist denn los?
Also sowohl zu Guttenberg als auch zu der Chat-Diskussion. Wir verschließen uns doch nicht Diskussionen. Ganz im Gegenteil. Wir werden erfreut, wenn manche Leute die Politik machen möchten und uns einmal öfters fragen und unseren Sachverstand mit zur Rate ziehen, statt irgendein Zeug vorzuschlagen, was nicht nur technisch total daneben ist.
Ja, aber da muss ich jetzt auch mit den Armen wieder sagen, das hat der Guttenberg doch versucht.
Herr Guttenberg war eine ganz besondere Situation. Herr Guttenberg ist ein deutscher Minister gewesen, der der Lüge entlarvt wurde, der dann aus der Politik ausgeschieden ist, einen Sabbatiger machen wollte und von der Bild betraut wurde, dass er doch bitte wieder zurückkommen soll. Und diesen Versuch wieder in die deutsche Politik zurückzukommen, hat er tatsächlich unternommen und er hat dafür eine Torte ins Gesicht bekommen und sich seitdem nicht wieder in Deutschland politisch blicken lassen.
Ja, und da könnte man jetzt sozusagen, um diese Position auch zu drinnen sagen, so, na das ist ja super, da hat sozusagen mal jemand, der tatsächlich wegen schlechten Voraussetzungen das Gespräch gesucht hat, also möglicherweise wollte er sich dann nicht schmücken, aber es war halt eine Gelegenheit. Und alles, was einem einfällt, ist ihm ein Tort ins Gesicht zu werfen. Ich meine, kann man, erzielt man so Leute?
Das war Herr von und zu, ich bin erschüttert, Guttenberg, der einfach seine Visionen des Internets und was er dort bereit ist, nach draußen zu tragen, schon dort einfach klar und deutlich manifestiert hat. Ich denke, das ist echt vergebene Liebesmühe. Und man würde ihn noch adeln, wenn man sich mit ihnen unterhält. Und deswegen dachte ich, dass diese gefrorene Torte da auch schon ganz angemessen war, die er da abbekommen hat.
Also es ist vielleicht generell so, dass es helfen könnte, wenn man da noch einen Schritt mehr drauf zugeht, ein bisschen mehr investiert, statt immer nur sozusagen die brennenden Ruinen einzureißen, damit das Feuer nicht überspringt?
Na, der Klaas Computer Club setzt sich da auch immer mit den up-and-coming-Politikern zusammen und versucht dann in Hintergrundgesprächen, denen so Dinge zu erklären, dass wir ja nicht, keine Ahnung, wollen, dass hier allkeiner Ausbildungsnetzwerke in Deutschland entstehen, weil wir es einfach für komplett unrealistisch halten. Wir unterhalten uns da auch, aber wir hängen es halt nicht so plakativ auf. Also wir vermitteln da schon unsere Agenda, aber wir wollen nicht, dass sich dann irgendeine politische Partei da mit dem Label schmückt, dass sie da CCC-approved politics betreiben würde.
Also das wollte ich jetzt auch noch sagen, also der ganze Sinn und Zweck von EDRI ist es ja auch hier in Brüssel die ganze Zeit mit Leuten zu reden. Also wir reden, reden, reden von morgens bis abends und ich habe ja eben schon mal gesagt, also wir werden auch zu Expertengruppen eingeladen von der Kommission und wir machen in super vielen Gruppen mit zur RFID, zu dem Internet der Dinge, zu Notice and Take Down und also uns vorzuwerfen, dass wir mit den Leuten nicht reden, das ist ja schon dreist.
Man muss es aber mal gefragt haben. Wir werden gleich noch eine halbe Stunde sozusagen versuchen, die ganze Sache zu einem runden Abschluss zu bringen und machen vorab eine kleine Pause und zwar wie ihr sicherlich möglicherweise schon vermut habt, fürs Fritz Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr.
Live und neu und gut.
Wann genau und wo genau? Fritzee. Lexi und Kay Paul. Live von neu und gut.
Empfohlen von Fritz.
Und das hört man um kurz vor halb 12. Nachrichten mit Jonte Weyland.
In Ostdeutschland sind mehr als 4.000 Kinder und Jugendliche an verunreinigtem Essen erkrankt. Ein Sprecher des Robert-Koch-Instituts sagte, dass Berlin, Brandenburg, Sachsen und Thüringen betroffen sind. Nach RBB-Informationen sind in Brandenburg mehr als 1.100 Kinder und Jugendliche erkrankt, in Berlin etwa 400. Auslöser ist wahrscheinlich das Essen des Großanbieters für Kita- und Schulessen Sodexo aus Thüringen. Inzwischen ist auch das Bundesamt für Verbraucherschutz und Lebensmittelsicherheit eingeschaltet worden. Der ständige Euro-Rettungsschirm ESM kommt. Heute Nachmittag hat Bundespräsident Gauck die Ratifizierungsurkunde unterschrieben. Damit kann der Rettungsschirm in knapp zwei Wochen in Kraft treten. Er hat eine Höhe von 500 Milliarden Euro und soll pleite bedrohte Euroländer unterstützen. Deutschland beteiligt sich am Rettungsschirm mit maximal 190 Milliarden Euro. Berlins Inn-Senator Henkel muss nicht vor dem NSU-Untersuchungsausschuss des Bundestages aussagen. Die Ausschussmitglieder wiesen einen Antrag der Grünen ab. Auch Berlins Polizeipräsidentin Koppers wird nicht vorgeladen. Die Grünen wollen Henkel zu seinen Erkenntnissen zur Faumann-Affäre befragen. Zuletzt war bekannt geworden, dass die Berliner Polizei jahrelang mit dem mutmaßlichen NSU-Unterstützer Thomas S zusammengearbeitet hat. Diese Informationen waren dem Untersuchungsausschuss mehr als ein halbes Jahr vorenthalten worden. Henkel hat inzwischen einen Sonderermittler eingesetzt. Trotz heftiger Proteste in der Bevölkerung will die spanische Regierung ihre Sparbemühungen im kommenden Jahr noch einmal verstärken. Das Kabinett verabschiedete in Madrid den Etatentwurf für 2013. Finanzminister Montoro sagte, dass 40 Milliarden Euro eingespart werden sollen. Die Etats der Ministerien sollen um durchschnittlich 12% gekürzt werden. Die Gehälter der Beamten und der Angestellten im öffentlichen Dienst werden für ein weiteres Jahr eingefroren. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin haben wir es überall zwischen 14 und 15 Grad, Wittenberge 11, Angermünde 12, Neuropin 13 und Potsdam, Cottbus und Frankfurt melden 14 Grad. Nachts bleibt es weiter regnerisch und wolkig, erst später lockert es dann etwas auf und die Temperaturen sinken auf 12 bis 10 Grad. Morgen wird es dann wieder regnerisch und wolkig und das Ganze bei 15 bis 18 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin Tiergartenstraße des 17. Juni. Zwischen Jetzakrabinstraße und Brandenburger Tor gibt es eine Vollsperrung wegen der Vorbereitung zum Berlin-Marathon. Ab morgen früh um 6 Uhr wird die Sperrung bis zum Großen Stern erweitert. Der Kreisverkehr rund um die Siegessäule bleibt jedoch frei. Gesperrt wird außerdem die Jetzakrabinstraße sowie die Ebertstraße zwischen Bärenstraße und Scheidemannstraße. Und dann noch nach Brandenburg A10 nördlicher Berliner Ringrichtung, Dreieck Haveland zwischen Mühlenbeck und Birkenwerder befinden sich Personen auf der Fahrbahn. Fahrt hier also bitte besonders vorsichtig. Sonst überall, wo es geht, eine gute Fahrt. Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB. Und wenn ihr den Fritz Night Flight von letzter Nacht verpasst habt oder ihn einfach noch mal hören wollt, dann hört ihn doch einfach noch mal.
So oft ihr wollt und wann ihr wollt.
Eine Woche lang im Musikstream. Auf FritzD.
Heute Chaosradio im Blue Moon. Zu Gast vom Chaos Computer Club sind Ilf und Erdgeist. Hallo und guten Abend noch mal. Außerdem Andre Meister vom Blog Netzpolitik. Hallo und guten Abend. Und Kirsten Fiedler von EDRI. Eine Advocacy-Gruppe. Gibt es auch ein deutsches Wort für eigentlich?
Bürgerrechtsorganisation.
Eine Bürgerrechtsorganisation in Brüssel. Drei Leute versorgen dort das gesamte europäische Parlament. Wir haben heute geredet über Clean IT und über die Art und Weise, wie in der, wie in Europa Sicherheitspolitik gemacht wird. Ich möchte jetzt gerne sozusagen noch eine kurze Frage stellen. Wir haben auch schon darüber geredet, was dieses Projekt war, woher der Gedanke kommt, dass sowas immer wieder passiert. Und die einzige Frage ist jetzt, wie handeln wir das in Zukunft? Kirsten, erst mal nach Brüssel. Was sind denn so die konkreten Pläne? Was steht denn als nächstes an in dieser Richtung? Oder ist jetzt mit Clean IT endlich alles gegessen und wir haben unsere Ruhe?
Ja, schön wär's. Dann könnte ich einpacken und nach Hause gehen. Also ja, wie gesagt, Clean IT ist ja nur ein einziges Symptom eines allgemeinen Trends. Und im Moment gibt es noch andere Projekte, wie zum Beispiel die CEO Coalition, wo es um Kinder- und Jugendschutz geht. Und da machen auch alle möglichen Unternehmen mit, unter anderem Microsoft, Google, Facebook und so weiter. Und die haben sich in Arbeitsgruppen unterteilt. Und zwar hat Microsoft die Arbeitsgruppe Notice and Take Down inne. Facebook hat den Vorsitz der Arbeitsgruppe Datenschutz.
Ich hätte das gerne noch mal langsam. Facebook hat den Vorsitz in einer Arbeitsgruppe, die erst um Datenschutz geht.
Datenschutz, genau. Aber das wirklich lustige, also eher gesagt traurige in der letzten Zeit, waren die Diskussionen in der Arbeitsgruppe Notice and Take Down. Und da ging es auch um alle möglichen freiwilligen Maßnahmen, die Unternehmen durchführen sollten. Und unter anderem hat Microsoft da halt enthusiastisch für die Firmen eigene FotoDNA-Software geworben. Das Ding soll irgendwie Bilder analysieren. Das ist quasi ein Upload-Filter wie Content ID. Die analysiert Bilder, die Missbrauch darstellen, selbst wenn die geschnitten oder verzerrt wurden. Und dann soll das halt weitere Uploads verhindern.
Dann habt ihr also auf jeden Fall genug zu tun. Jetzt sitzt möglicherweise da jemand vor seinem neuartigen Rundfunk-Empfangsgerät und denkt sich so, die armen drei Leute in Brüssel machen die Arbeit ganz alleine. Was kann ich tun?
Also was die Leute tun können, ist sich weiterhin informieren. Also wir veröffentlichen ziemlich viel auf der EDRI-Webseite. Oder halt auf öffentliche Konzentration der EU-Kommission antworten. Oder halt den ganzen tollen Organisationen, die die Arbeit machen, ein bisschen Geld zukommen zu lassen.
Was war das gerade das Vorliege, was du gesagt hast? Öffentliche Konsultation? Was genau ist das?
Also, bevor die EU-Kommission einen Gesetzesvorschlag vorlegt, startet sie normalerweise öffentliche Konsultation. Da kann dann jeder darauf antworten. Und das ist wirklich ganz wichtig, dass auch Bürgerinnen und Bürger und alle möglichen Bürgerrechtsorganisationen das auch machen. Weil sonst antwortet halt nur die Industrie.
Ah ja, da kann man sich also sagen, selber mal einbringen. Quasi die Stimme des Bürgers. Habt ihr gehört, Leute? Kirsten, dann vielen Dank fürs Mitmachen.
Eine letzte Anmerkung hatte ich noch. Kirsten, seid doch nicht so bescheiden. Auch EDRI lebt von diesem komischen Geld, von dem die Leute schon mal gehört haben. Das ist echt wichtig. Wie gesagt, vor zwei Jahren war Joe leider noch alleine. Jetzt gibt es immerhin drei Leute, aber auch das sind noch viel zu wenige, um die ganzen Sachen, die da in Brüssel und drum herum passieren, monitoren und begleiten zu können. Auf der Seite edri.org gibt es links einen Banner Spenden. Denn wie andere Organisationen auch, lebt und braucht auch EDRI Spenden von Leuten, die das für eine gute Sache halten, aber sich jetzt vielleicht nicht im Gestrüpp von Kommissionen, DGs und Parlamenten auskennen.
Also wenn euch das so kompliziert ist, bewerft ihr doch da einfach mit Geld.
Ja, danke euch.
Und viel Glück bei der Arbeit in Brüssel noch. So, da haben wir also in Brüssel einen Einblick hinter die Brüsseler Kulissen gehabt. Wie sieht es bei euch aus? Andre, du machst ja für Netzpolitik ganz viel. Wie macht ihr da sozusagen einfach weiter Berichterstattung? Wie ist das eigentlich? Macht ihr das da manchmal im Sinne von Vorausberichterstattung oder wartet ihr einfach, dass der nächste Skandal kommt und seid dann immer fleißig dabei? Du hast ja jetzt heute zum Beispiel noch so eine Rede transkribiert von irgendeinem EU-Politiker. Wird das so weiterlaufen?
Also Netzpolitik beobachtet natürlich schon seit Jahren und hat fest vor, dass auch weiterhin zu tun alle möglichen Themen, die rund um Politik und Internet in beide Richtungen zu tun haben. Wir können auch nicht immer voraussehen, was als nächstes aufpoppen wird. Wir sind da auf die Mitarbeit von Bündnisorganisationen, vom Chaos Computer Club, aber auch EDRI, anderen Netzwerken, die wir so haben, angewiesen. Und manchmal passiert es auch andersrum, dass Leute auf uns zukommen und wir einen kleinen Scoop landen können mit einer Nachricht, die vorher noch niemand auf dem Schirm hatte.
Gibt es sozusagen konkret Verdacht, was in einem Monat unser aufregendes Tagesende wird?
Drohnen. Drohnen? Wieso? Drohnen sind coole Spielzeuge und mit Drohnen kann man überwachen.
Gibt es auch aus EU-Perl aus?
Das wird auf jeden Fall kommen. Ich weiß nicht wer, aber irgendjemand wird dann mal den, keine Ahnung, wenn im Spiegel mal wieder oder in einer Zeit so ein Artikel drüber ist und findet einen Lokalpolitiker, dass es eine gute Idee ist, und dann lässt er sich das erklären von seinem Neffen. Und dann kann ich mir ganz gut vorstellen, dass da die nächste große Kampagne...
Wie drängt es jetzt gerade für mich die Fahrer auf? Habt ihr, ich sage immer jetzt ja ihr, so global ihr Aktivisten, habt ihr so kleine Wetten, also Fußballfans haben ja so ein Tippspiel. Habt ihr so Wetten am Laufen, so ok, das nächste alberne Gesetz, das vorgeschlagen wird?
Ja, also im Wohnzimmer sitzen wir und gucken dann, ob als nächstes wieder Naziskinder, Pädophile oder Terroristen oder was wieder auf die Tagesordnung gesetzt wird immer.
Ah, ok, also es wird nicht gewettet, welches schlimme Gesetz als nächstes kommt, sondern wie es begründet wird. Ok, dann hatten wir jetzt gerade Terroristen mit Clean IT. Was wird denn das nächste dann sein?
Muss man mal an den Turnus gucken. Ich habe eine Wette auf, dass demnächst wieder Kindesmissbrauch kommt.
Ok, gut, werden wir dann an gegebener Stelle hier berichten. Wir schließen damit das Thema ab. Es sei denn, ihr habt jetzt noch eine ganz dringende Frage. Dann hättet ihr jetzt auch noch Zeit unter 0331 77 97 120 anzurufen. Wir haben aber noch ein paar kleine Hausmeistereien für euch. Also der Club hat ein paar Daten, die am Start sind, Herr Erdgeist.
Genau so sind Datenspuren, die in Dresden stattfinden. Das ist vor am 13. und 14. Oktober. Und die Dresdner haben eigentlich seit Jahren ein ziemlich cooles Programm, was es sehr gut schafft, Technik und Politik auf eine spannende Art und Weise zusammenzuführen, in Form von Vorträgen und Workshops. Und das ist irgendwie auch eine total familiäre Atmosphäre. Und ich kann da zu den Datenspuren eigentlich immer nur...
Also wie das Chaosradio nur zwei Tage lang?
Ja, mit Anfassen.
Ich sehe dein leises, bedauernder Stimme. Gibt es noch mehr? Warte, du hattest glaube ich die Tage noch gar nicht gesagt.
Doch, doch hatte ich 13. Das 14. Oktober. Und auf datenspuren.de stehen eigentlich alle spannenden Informationen dazu. Alright. Ansonsten wollte, glaube ich... Nö, sonst habe ich hier nur Nachrichten. Der Datengarten in Berlin ist nämlich just heute parallel zu der Sendung. Deswegen kann ich da leider nicht mehr drauf referenzieren. Da ist heute eine Wikiergruppe, die davon berichtet, wie sie Wikipedia maschinenlesbarer hinbekommt. Und finde ich eigentlich einen ganz spannenden Punkt, den ich jetzt wegen des Chaosradios gar nicht live mitmachen kann.
Du guter. Unter aller Dank ist dir gewiss. Man kann aber dazu sagen, der Datengarten ist eine regelmäßige Veranstaltung, oder?
Inzwischen wieder regelmäßige Veranstaltung, ja.
Kann man sich da irgendwo informieren an Stellen, die gepflegt werden?
Berlinccc.de, das ist ein Wiki. Dort versuchen wir einigermaßen regelmäßig abzudaten, was bei uns im Club in der Marienstraße 11 in Mitte so abgeht.
Alles klar, könnt aber gucken. Wir kommen jetzt zu den Nachrichten. Ich habe hier ein paar Schlagzeilen. Ich werde die mal vortragen. Du sagst bitte, worum es genau geht. Ich schreibe zum Beispiel als erste Schlagzeile Sternchen 2767, Sternchen 3855 Raute.
Wer einen Samsung Galaxy 3 hat, der hat gerade echt Freunde. Wenn er nämlich diesen MMI in sein Telefon eingeht, dann wird ein Factory Reset durchgeführt. Und das heißt, dass man dann so ziemlich alle Dateneinstellungen und so ziemlich alles wieder verliert, was man da auf seinem Telefon veranstaltet hat. Was wirklich fiese ist, dass man diesen Vendor Implemented MMI sich auch von Remote ausführen lassen kann, indem man einfach auf der Webseite, die man besucht, einen DIV. Man kann auf eine Webseite gehen.
Ganz ruhig. Erklärst du das so, dass es alle verstehen?
Ich bin so doll aufgeregt, weil ich das so witzig finde. Man kann, ähnlich wie früher die ersten Exploits für Browser passiert sind, dass man bestimmte Dinge fernsteuern kann, wie zum Beispiel einen Kalkulator-Exe aufrufen. Wenn der Internet Explorer sich über Listen lässt, kann man dieses Telefon auch dazu bringen, diesen Factory Reset beim Besuch einer Webseite auszuführen.
Also ihr geht mit eurem Mobiltelefon auf eine Webseite und es macht zonk und dann ist das Mobiltelefon wieder so, als ob ihr es gerade ganz frisch ausgepackt hättet. Das ist ja total großartig und da möchte ich nur mal sagen, apropos Internet Explorer. Was war da nochmal los? Niemand weiß, dass genau der Internet Explorer hatte. Ich kam mir wirklich vor, wie in der guten alten Zeit. Es gab mal wieder ein Sicherheitslöck im Internet Explorer. Früher kannte man das, da gab es das jeden Monat irgendwie. Tatsächlich kamen jetzt raus, der Internet Explorer 6, 7, 8, 9 und 10 hat eine Sicherheitslücke, die so schlimm ist, dass man auf der Besuch an der Webseite ausreicht, dass man komplett den Rechner übernehmen kann. Das fand ich ganz großartig.
Ich kenne halt niemanden mehr, der den Internet Explorer ernsthaft einsetzt.
Das ist Monoxid.
Entschuldigung, nur auf meinem Arbeitsrechner.
Der liest ja auch vom Radio das Internet vor.
Was? Das würde ich niemals tun.
Doch, vorhin aus dem Chat.
Jetzt wird mir hier die Hörerbeteiligung vorgebracht. Ich fand diese Meinung tatsächlich so spannend, weil in Kreisen von Leuten, die so technikaffin sind, da ist genau das die Reaktion so, ach guck mir, Internet Explorer benützt doch eh keiner mehr. Aber ich glaube tatsächlich, das ist tatsächlich auch noch gefährlich.
Dann ruft Mutti an.
Genau, dann ruft Mutti an. Oder der Arbeitsadmin, dem sagt man das, und der guckt dich so an so, haaaaa? Also ich finde, so eine Nachricht sollte man trotzdem noch verfolgen. Dann habe ich hier etwas zu Kimbell und dem Premierminister von Neuseeland. Was ist da passiert?
Kimbell ist ja ein aus Deutschland ausgewanderter toller Hecht, der damals durch das Verpetzen seiner Kumpels hier und Verkaufen von raubkopierter Software sich einen doch ziemlich schlechten Namen gemacht hat. Und der hat ja mega upload aufgezogen und sich eine goldene Nase verdient. Und nachdem die Amerikaner in Neuseeland ein bisschen Druck gemacht haben, wurde er dort vom Geheimdienst eine Weile überwacht und illegal abgehört und dann in einer ziemlich martialischen Aktion auch festgenommen und für mehrere Tage eingesperrt. Und für das illegale Abhören hat sich heute der Premierminister von Neuseeland öffentlich entschuldigt bei ihm. Soweit ist es also gekommen, dass irgendwelche, möchte gern super Spezialhacker unsere Sympathie abbekommen müssen, weil sie in die Mühlen eines wild frei drehenden, ehemaligen Rechtsstaats geraten sind.
So, da hab ich gehört, irgendwo wird Pfeilscheren legal?
Ja, Pfeilscheren für private Zwecke ist inzwischen in Portugal, naja, nicht legal, aber der Staatsanwalt, der Generalstaatsanwalt hat wegen der Fülle von Fällen, die dort jetzt verhandelt werden sollen, einmal ein generelles Verfolgungsstopp für Pfeilscheren auf privater Ebene verhangen. Das heißt also, dass das Massenabmahn-Geschäft, wie in Deutschland und Portugal eigentlich hier gerade verboten wurde.
Besteht da Hoffnung, dass man es möglicherweise übernimmt? Nein.
Nein, das wäre bestimmt schon mal eine tolle Sendung, wenn wir die nicht schon gemacht hätten.
So, dann gibt es eine Crypto-Party.
Ja, es gibt eine Crypto-Party, in der, ja, wie heißt das? Evangelisten, nein Evangelisten sind die, die Evangelien aufschreiben. Die Leute, die andere Leute zu Cryptografie bekehren wollen, sich zusammentreffen und ich soll auf die Crypto-Party hinweisen, aber jetzt nicht speziell auf die nächste in Berlin, weil die auch schon sehr überlaufen ist. Aber auf cryptoparty.org kann man sich in seiner Nähe das nächste Meeting da mal heraussuchen und dort einfach partizipieren, um sich vielleicht einen generellen Überblick über Alltags-Cryptografie, was man so an PGP benutzen kann, wie man in seinem Browser sich die Zertifikate angucken soll, um diesen Überblick zu bekommen. Und ich war da noch nicht bei gewesen, aber Leute, denen ich vertraue, dass die da schon ein cleveres Händchen für Veranstaltungen haben, haben wir dir empfohlen, dort darauf hinzuweisen.
Und falls ihr dennoch mal vorbeigucken wollt, noch einen kleinen Platz ergattern wollt am 28. September, ist das glaube ich in Berlin. Aber wie gesagt, Crypto Party Org. So, dann sind wir eigentlich durch, oder? Es ist jetzt 23.48 Uhr?
Ja, du hast einfach zu schnell geredet.
Ich habe überhaupt gar nichts gesagt.
Also ich sehe da noch mindestens eins auf der Liste. Ja bitte? Open Plan B. Ein Open Data Projekt von befreundeten Aktivisten, die schon seit einer ganzen Weile mit Verkehrsunternehmen diskutieren, die auf riesigen Datenbergen sitzen, von ihren Fahrplänen und Haltestellen, Orten und all möglichen Informationen dazu, die zwar überall aushängen, die es aber noch nicht wirklich digital für alle gibt. Jetzt hat gerade Google einen Deal mit der Deutschen Bahn gemacht, um in Google Maps zu integrieren, wenn man von Ort A nach Ort B im roten Planer will, dass dann auch öffentliche Verkehrsmittel angezeigt werden. Nur leider hat nur Google diese Daten von der Deutschen Bahn bekommen, was ein Unding ist, weil wir, also die Deutsche Bahn war immer Staatsunternehmer, bzw. der Staat hält immer noch die größten Anteile. Wir haben dafür bezahlt, wir wollen die Daten auch haben und vor allem wir können viel coolere Sachen damit machen, als die Deutsche Bahn das selber kann. Also ist Michael Kreil hingegangen, ein befreundeter Open Data Aktivist, hat die Windows-Offline-Fahrplan-App oder irgend so ein Zeug von der Webseite runtergeladen, wo der ganze Fahrplan in obskuren Datenformaten drin war, hat das befreit in ein normales Datenformat gemacht und hat das auf BitTorrent gestellt. Das heißt, die Fahrplandaten der Deutschen Bahn und einige andere Verkehrsunternehmen, unter anderem der Verkehrsverbund Berlin, Brandenburg, VBB, sind jetzt auf BitTorrent frei für alle herunterladbar. Mehr Open Data für alle.
Aber dabei halten Sie doch, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, eher um einen symbolischen Akt als um etwas Praktisches, oder?
Nee, das heißt doch, wie die Datensätze in Offline zur Verfügung zu haben, ist doch Sahne. Die ganze Zeit die Bahn querien zu müssen und zu gucken und dass Ihre Server dich dann nicht irgendwann filtern, sondern einfach das bei dir lokal selber mal nachzugucken, ob dir wirklich die Bahn immer die günstigste Verbindung raussucht oder ob man vielleicht noch bessere Ideen hat, wie man Routing wichten kann. Vielleicht, ja, ich habe ein Fahrrad, wie komme ich denn am besten durch die Gegend? Also kleine, ziemlich coole Gadgets, die die Bahn dir nicht anbietet, kannst du endlich selber rechnen auf den Datenmuster nicht durch deren hässliches, ich habe nicht genau verstanden, ob jetzt mit Friedrichstraße S war nur Friedrichstraße oder Friedrichstraße irgendwo draußen in Steglitz Mainz. Ist doch viel, viel cooler, wenn man mit dem Datenmaterial selber spielen kann.
Ist das jetzt sozusagen, wurde das dann auch zum Anlass genommen, dass die Meilen sagt, naja gut, dann nehmt doch lieber unsere richtigen Daten? Oder ist das jetzt einfach nur dieses Ding, ist jetzt im Netz und das war es dann auch wieder?
Die Deutsche Bahn sperrt sich leider noch ein bisschen. Andere wie der VBB hier in Berlin und Brandenburg sind weiter und wollen tatsächlich demnächst ihre kompletten Fahrplandaten in einem offenen Format für alle zum Download unter einer freien Lizenz zur freien Verwendung zur Verfügung stellen. Irgendwie hat die Deutsche Bahn das noch nicht so ganz kapiert. Da sind halt, und da sind wir wieder bei den Generationenproblemen, noch viele Hindernisse und Ängste vor diesem Internet. Da könnte ja irgendjemand eine schlechte Deutsche Bahn Fahrplan-App machen. Wie es zum Beispiel eine bestimmte schon ist. Ich glaube, die könnten alle nur noch besser werden. Wenn man die Kreativität der Masse da drauf loslässt, dann werden da auch tolle Sachen daraus entstehen.
Ich muss jetzt auch unbedingt mal das Internet vorlesen, weil da geht gerade durch den Chat noch, dass der Internet Explorer wird wohl noch von mindestens so 33% der Surfer verwendet. Ich weiß zwar nicht, wo das Zitat her ist, aber ich mag dieses Wort Surfer. Da schwingt immer Silversurfer mit, wie keine Ahnung, so komisch verdrahtet.
Es gibt doch dieses schöne Lied.
Ist das das, was du nur am Ende der Sendung spielst?
Nee, das ist ein anderes. Da haben wir noch ein bisschen Zeit für.
Noch ein anderes.
Ich bin wirklich ein bisschen erschüttert und gerade ein bisschen auch sprachlos. Sprach und ratlos.
Wieso? Das Internet Explorer ist wegen?
Nee, wegen der Zeit.
Ach so.
Aber glücklicherweise ist er für die 15 Jahre Chaosradio und das ist noch nie passiert. Aber von dieser lustigen Creative Commons Musik habe ich natürlich noch einen kleinen Song dabei. Und da geht es, das kommen wir vielleicht auch auf die EU-Politik, beziehend um einen großen Fisch. Ne, zwei. Ich danke euch nämlich, Ilf, Andre und Erdgeist, dass ihr jeweils und das noch mal genauer erklärt habt. Und mein Name ist Markus Richter und ich bitte euch, lasst euch nicht überwachen und macht immer schön eure Pack-Ups.